all right I will
the
February 1st
meeting of the hearing of hearings of uh
on
resources Recreation and development
bills uh will everyone stand for we
please join with me in a salute the
whole Glory I pledge allegiance to the
one nation
indivisible with liberty and justice
right
yeah
first bill on the agenda
is House Bill 186 relative to waivers
for alternative sewage Disposal Systems
and uh
recognize representative stavis and I
think I would also recognize
representative Sykes
representative
good morning Mr chair and members of the
committee thank you so much for hearing
this this morning
this bill was put for forward at the
request and in consultation with Grafton
County officials
since the LSR was drafted and released
we have learned that there is much more
work to be done on this bill and to fill
you in on the details of that work I'd
like to turn this over to representative
Sykes who is chair of the executive
representative Sykes the floor is yours
thank you representative thank you Mr
chairman rep members of the resources
and economic is it Economic Development
resources I forget let's see resources
Recreation Recreation that's the piece I
was forgetting thank you there isn't
much in the way of Economic Development
no well maybe sort of kind of anyways so
I wanted to because I'm chair of the
Grafton County delegation I've been in
pretty close contact and consultation
with uh the Commissioners and the um
the professional staff of Grafton County
Government
and um
the details of the Genesis of this bill
was there's a single small company
Woodsville Power and Light that provides
electricity Water and Sewer to the
Grafton County Complex because it's such
a tiny company
um
the rates are exceptionally High
the just to keep your perspective
some ways in the neighborhood of about a
hundred thousand dollars a month is what
it costs to run just the County Complex
and the the County Complex represents 25
percent of their business
so it's a really complex issue because
Grafton County taxpayers are paying
a really serious amount of money
by RSA
Grafton County can look for alternative
sources of electricity that's new new
developments in the last few years they
can also look for for the example of
putting in some artesian wells to
replace the water
however under existing RSA
then they have to
ask for a waiver from the the company
that provides sewer
that company has refused to
decline to give a waiver
um unfortunately
there hadn't been a really great working
relationship between the county complex
and the company
so that became the Genesis of the
Commissioners asking for this bill to be
introduced
um in the meantime and this is the
important point in the meantime
um
some really excellent conversations have
begun
um
we have learned things from Des that
gave us pause as sponsors we have
learned things from the New Hampshire
Municipal Association that gave us some
pause
um and we're they are both those
organizations are talking with the
Woodsville Power and Light and also with
the County Government
and we are making progress towards
finding a better solution perhaps even a
non-legislative solution but I wanted to
make it clear that this is progress not
final solution
so
representative stavis the prime sponsor
and myself
um we are requesting respectfully that
you retain this bill
so that we have time to continue those
discussions and hopefully find an
excellent solution for all the taxpayers
of Grafton County and as well as the
any questions by members of the
committee
seeing none
chair recognizes
[Music]
thank you Mr chair and H Grace for the
municipal Association we agree that
retention is the best option at this
point in time and that's all I want to
again any questions by members of the
committee
none thank you
okay
uh
is that Trace Tracy Tracy woods from New
hi Tracy wood I'm the administrator of
the Wastewater engineering Bureau at New
Hampshire Des that resides in the Water
Division under rainy Pelletier we have
provided a letter of concern today if
this bill were to be moved forward you
would see our concerns we are happy that
the bill is being retained while the
parties are having discussions and we
have been a part of those discussions
and we hope that they will come up with
a mutually agreeable solution but we do
have concerns If This Were to move
forward and the biggest is that
wastewater treatment facilities are
designed for a certain flow and loading
and if you make my major modifications
to the flows and loadings coming in that
changes the treatment process and so
there's concerns on that level that
taking out a major contributor would
have a detrimental impact on the
operation of the wastewater treatment
facility and in addition when
a wastewater treatment facility is built
you're basing that on a certain number
of users that's the flows and loadings
and then that determines your rate
structure so
pulling out a big contributor changes
the rate structure and that puts the
rates out on the other users when that
entity pulls out so you'll see that as
some of our concerns in our letter so
that's it for today but thank you for
for listening
thank you any questions by members of
the committee
representative Darby
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question just I just want to confirm
you your agree with retaining this
absolutely I think that's the best path
forward and I'm glad that the parties
are having discussions and that we're
being a part of that thanks mm-hmm
representative harp
thank you thank you for taking my
question
um I just had a question with the idea
of the rate in telling people that they
can or can't tie in that's my
understanding in Massachusetts where I
work that if a line is put in the street
and under Title Five they say if your
system fails you have to tie in but they
don't I believe mandate tying in if your
system is still
um
passing
so I'm just confused by why here you you
set the rate by everybody supposedly
tying in maybe at some point in 2050
everybody will be tied in but that
really impacts the design of the system
yes yes so grafting when they built the
original wastewater treatment facility
Grafton County was part of that design
now you're talking about adding new
users in after the design of the plant
and each plant is built with a certain
amount of capacity for future growth you
have to look out when you're designing a
major wastewater treatment facility you
have to look out 20 years and what's the
growth projected in that time period in
your particular situation
as far as people connecting in you are
correct so if a town has an existing
system and they're doing a sewer
extension
not everyone is mandated to connect on
especially if they're extending out and
some people are in private systems they
do wait until they fail and then when
the system fails most municipalities
will ask that they connect in a lot of
times sewer extensions are being done in
areas where think about around a pond or
a lake and you have all these individual
septic systems and they've been in there
for quite some time and they're all
failing and in order to protect public
health and the environment and the water
quality and that water body
they'll be doing a sewer extension and
eliminate the private systems but in
that case usually everyone's on board
because everyone who lives around that
Ponder water body wants to protect it
right because they're using it for
recreation
seeing none
and
finally uh Kate hergan
from the New Hampshire Association
counties that I've
did I pronounced that correctly pretty
darn close thank you Mr chairman my name
is Kate Horgan I represent the New
Hampshire Association of counties which
is all your elected and appointed
officials in County government in this
case we would ask that the committee
retain the bill as the parties continue
to work towards a non-legislative
seeing no one thank you very much thank
you
having no additional pink cards
anyone else wish to speak if not I will
close the hearing on
and uh
next bill is and we will not you have to
wait
let's do that
uh
hospital that's a 10 205 is in 10 is 10
45 so
you can now go around and visit
introduce yourselves
up
like to call a hearing to order on House
Bill 205
relative to testing private Wells
I will call the
first the sponsor for sponsor
foreign
thank you very much and thank you for
allowing me to introduce HB 205 to your
committee this bill actually emerged as
part of the work of the Seacoast
Commission on long-term goals and
requirements for drinking water which is
a mouthful you have to drink a glass of
water actually after you say the whole
thing but one of the things that the
commission is charged with doing is
assessing threats to drinking water
supplies and also preparing
contingencies in case of droughts and
other types of emergency including
contamination emergencies
the commission also monitors the work of
different state agencies like the
Department of Environmental Services we
actually have a member of of the
commission who is from Des and he briefs
us quite frequently on issues regarding
drought contamination and drinking water
supplies across the Seacoast
um part of the commission's work because
so many people in New Hampshire have
private Wells has been trying to better
understand the level of contamination in
private uh well drinking water
um in uh in 2021 one of the things the
commission uh uh did was it applied for
and received some funding to pay for a
pilot program to test private wells in
Seacoast communities for traditional
contaminants as well as pfas
um while the results are are really just
sort of starting to flicker in uh from
from that effort
um one of the things that actually uh
surprised us and and to be honest with
you blew us away uh last summer was a
presentation uh that uh the Department
of Environmental Services made to us uh
according to Des New Hampshire has about
000 private Wells
um and so far out of the ten thousand
private Wells sampled 86 percent had
detectable levels of pfas and 30 percent
of all the wells tested that's 30
percent of the 10 000 plus Wells that
were tested had pfas levels exceeding
state standards for one of the four uh
regulated forms of pfas
that surprised us and it was one of the
reasons why the legislative members of
the the commission decided to to
basically take a look at a bill from
2020 HB 667 which passed in the house
and died because of covid
um
that um that would have required that
that basically would have required a
private well installers to test for
certain contaminants
before and uh and and notify the uh the
homeowners of the presence of those
contaminants
one of the biggest differences between
hb667
and the current bill that's in front of
you now is HB 667 did not include pfas
chemicals I'm not 100 sure why the
reason for that is but I think one of
the things that's become apparent over
the last uh several years and I know a
lot of this is especially had folks on
this committee pretty hard
um uh the level of knowledge that we
have about about these chemicals and the
dangers that they present is really
increased a Quantum level since where we
were in in 2020 which is the reason that
pfas chemicals are added to the bill
listen uh before you today
what uh HP 205 would do would be to add
the four regulated compounds pfas
compounds uh that uh that New Hampshire
currently regulates
um uh and it would also
add any additional it would also any
additional uh pfas compounds that uh
that Des adds administratively
would actually be added to to
requirements and the other part of the
bill I wanted to call your attention to
is uh is a requirement that if
detectable levels of other pfas
compounds are actually found in that
Community then
testing for those
compounds would also be required this is
how we get to things like Gen X in
Merrimack in Litchfield and Bedford and
other communities that have been
affected by Saint goban Gen X to this
point is not one of the regular related
chemicals in in New Hampshire
but I think the evidence is becoming uh
clearer and clearer that these chemicals
are causing uh are causing harm uh and
what this bill would uh would do would
be to give homeowners who have new
private Wells installed uh
basically the the ability to know what
they're dealing with it doesn't require
them to actually remediate the
contamination so we're not requiring
that people install
filtration systems or anything of that
nature would it would it what it does do
is is it would force uh pump installers
to uh to secure testing to provide the
test results to the homeowner and it
would also require the homeowner if
there are contaminants that actually are
detected to notify anyone who purchases
the property in the future that there
are contaminants in those Wells
so so basically this bill is about
helping people understand what it is
that they're dealing with
um uh and I think one of the biggest
takeaways uh for for us was the extent
of the problem
um I think we were kind of laboring
under the illusion that well gee you
know we know pfas is an issue in our
public drinking water supplies in my
community of Portsmouth actually all of
our current water sources have some
detectable levels of pfas but for some
reason and it was in most likely
ignorance
we just didn't think that the problem
extended to that level in private Wells
but hearing that 86 percent of the ten
thousand Wells that Des has tested also
have distractible levels of pfas and 30
percent have levels above the uh you
know the New Hampshire is actually very
very stringent
requirements
for the four compounds that are
regulated
it's just a warning sign and
unfortunately we're not in a position
where we can re regulate the
manufacturers of these chemicals they
still continue to go into the
environment there's a long legal process
and lawmaking process involved to
actually stop it at the source
but one of the things that we can do is
a better job of helping people
understand what they're dealing with and
and I think at the that's really the
root of what this bill is all about
we're trying to inform
homeowners of the situation they
potentially face and then we leave it up
to them as to how they want to address
it one of the things that I did want to
add is the state of New Hampshire also
has a program right now that if if
detectable levels of pfas are detected
in a private will you can actually
receive a five thousand dollar rebate
from the state
um uh for uh installing uh filtration
equipment to help to help remove it
so we're currently trying to address
this problem at multiple levels but but
as you can see
ten thousand Wells tested when we have a
quarter of a million wells in the state
of New Hampshire we have a lot of work
to do and there are a lot of people out
there who may not know that they're in
this situation so we want to make it
easier for them to do that
any questions members of the committee
representative wolf followed by
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
you have a quarter of a million wells in
the state of New Hampshire that exists
today
but you're only going after the new
wells that are being drilled
shouldn't there be legislation
we've got a seller has to have a or a
buyer has to have a well tested I don't
know which side you want to put it on
but
it should be going after the 250 000
Wells as opposed to the very small
number that are being drilled this year
or next year or Etc
is would that be a good idea sure
um I think one of the things that we're
trying to do is we're trying to get a
start here and then depending on
where the severity of the the problem
goes I think we can ex it's extend it
from there and if the committee decides
that that's something that that that you
would like to do I think that would be
uh finding a way to you know to so more
people could actually benefit from
testing uh you know would be good I
think the situation is that we currently
one of the one of the best times to do
testing like this and and one of the
most necessary times is one is when
people do put in a new well that's when
you really want to know you're putting
in a you basically you're putting in an
entire system
um but uh this is essentially a good
idea for anybody to do and I think uh
anybody who owns a private well in New
Hampshire given the level of natural
contaminants not just pfas but things
like Arsenic and copper and manganese
and some of the other things that some
of the other people testifying today
will will tell you about
um
we have an illusion I think that that
our well water is pure because it comes
from inside the ground but there are a
lot there are a lot of things inside the
ground and arsenic is a big one that can
hurt us if we're not aware of them and
we keep drinking it so so I think one of
the things we're hoping to do
is to raise awareness of the situation
through this bill of what our situation
is with private Wells
and I think one of the things we were
very much aware of is trying not to to
bite off more than we can chew in a
first bite but if you would if the
committee would like to bite off a
no more questions thank you
representative Darby
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question so this bill seems to have
you know two parts to it right one is
the testing part and then one is the
notification part I actually have
questions about both but I'll start with
the second piece which is the
notification part
when I read it and I I believe I've
signed this kind of
um you know notification before in the
previous language but when I read it the
the
um it becomes the language used is much
more alarmist
um and the last Clause of the existing
RSA says that basically there's nothing
to require that this bill that this
Clause even be provided because there's
no you know there's no ramifications if
it's not and so I wonder by making the
language of this clause
I mean I I would use the word word
alarmist a little bit if people might be
inclined to just omit it all together
since there is no lack and since there
I'm I'm not sure I'm not sure I get the
full uh so what I'm trying what I'm
referring to is in section you know if
you look at 477
4a2 which is on line 24 of the last page
right this is nothing in this section
shall be construed to have an impact on
the legal validity uh the transfer or
place any liability on a seller or
seller's agent so basically it says if
you don't provide this at this
notification there's no there's no
recourse so it makes me wonder
if by making the language you know
um more flagrant maybe that's too loud a
too strong a word that people just stop
including it at all if they're if
they're worried about it and if it was
toned down a little bit especially that
first paragraph and you just added this
section about pfas if it
if
um it might be more you know supported
by the broader you know real real to a
community
I think one of the things that I saw
happen with uh just looking at the
history of HB 667 is that the committee
did make several attempts uh the last
time uh to adjust that language
um and I and I think
um I would expect uh that if the com in
the language that I actually pulled is
where we essentially wound up with uh
with HP 667 if you would like to make
that language uh a stronger less
intimidating
um uh whatever you would like to do with
it that's fine I think the important
thing is that people are notified
um you know in you know in in a transfer
property that's just something uh that
you would want to know
um and I remember when I moved uh up to
New Hampshire from my home in
Connecticut one of the things that I had
to do was disclose that there had been
an oil tank buried in my front yard I
had to
to provide paperwork around the fact
that that oil tank had been removed and
that there was no trace of any petroleum
products uh in the soil or anything like
that so these things are actually you
know pretty common in in Property
Transfers around the country
um and given the emerging threat uh from
from pfas I think this is something that
or for a follow-up thank you Mr chair
um that's not the way I read what this
is saying this is not a
um this is saying
um these are common substances and you
should test your well for it rather than
um these substances have been found
that's that's the way I read you know
lines 5 through 13 on the last page this
is not saying this is not a declaration
so you're referring to
um uh Roman Roman numeral two nothing in
this section
no I I what you just described was these
decorations well we're going back and
forth on a
one area
uh
let's why don't we try to see if you
can't wrap it up if we can't wrap it up
let's go on to something else because
they're you know we there is a lot of
folks to testify that uh information may
come out out of that
testimony and then we still have to be
able to there's we have to then work on
the bill and that could be part of that
discussion
okay maybe I'll just move on can I have
a follow-on for the first part of the
first section of the bill talks about
you know basically the well driller has
to
um to um you know to do this testing on
the owner's behalf have you considered
um per you know providing the materials
have um having the well driller provide
the materials so the homeowner could
optionally
um do the do the drilling or do the
testing
so that the whole I'm sorry so material
so having had gone through this process
myself
I know that you can get the um the
materials to have the testing done by
the state and submit them yourself
and
um rather than having the contractor do
it on your behalf and then my question
is whether you have considered
um having the contractor provide you
know the sampling kit to the homeowner
so that they could submit it to the
state for the testing rather than
submitting it on their behalf and
ultimately charging for that
I I am not an expert in pfas testing but
um
having dealt with some of those test
kits and things like that and other
things as a homeowner one of the things
I would be concerned about
is
um is the homeowner you know doing the
sampling from the right place is there a
particular way it has to be done
um uh I think ensuring that the that the
pump installer is responsible for doing
it would ensure that it's done
consistently and and most likely
correctly
um I I don't think any of us may have
have ever sampled water for pfest before
and maybe it's easier than I think it is
or less complicated but if if it if it
if it gets to a point where it's
something that that homeowners can do my
hope would be that more of those
20 you know 240 000 homeowners who
haven't had their Wells sampled yet uh
would start would start to do it
um but uh I mean these are the things
that that we're going to need to look at
because the scope of this of this
problem
um looks you know potentially very very
large and this bill is actually a very
very small part of trying to get our our
arms around it
um you know beyond detection there's a
whole issue of of remediation there's
the whole issue of Health impacts when
we don't remediate in time
um uh you know that this is something
that we're starting to see in community
after community in New Hampshire
and uh in the legislature I think one of
the things we're able to do is we're
able to take a small piece uh and make
something good happen and I would kind
of put this bill in that category what's
a lot harder for us to do is to solve
the pfas problem
um in in one two or three bills and I
don't think we're going to get there but
I do think that there are small things
that we can do along the way that can
improve the situation
help reduce exposure for people who
otherwise would have been exposed and um
and I hope you uh agree to either give
the pet the bill or not to pass
recommendation or make a better bill out
of it and then give it a not to pass
any other
representative wrong for a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
um online on page two on line 33 when
you're adding language relative to radon
you mention how it uh it can increase oh
actually I'm sorry it's on line 30. you
mentioned resulting in levels of radon
that increase the risk of lung cancer
and other diseases but in other areas of
that section when you're
discussing pfas and lead and arsenic
you're not mentioning the health impacts
was there a deliberate reason for that
no I I think one of the things that I
wanted to do
um in the bill was to keep as much
similarity as I could with the original
language of
hb667 so these were changes that were
actually made to 667 before it was
passed in the house uh in in 2020 uh if
there is if you if if the committee
decided to put information uh about
additional health impact for some of
those other chemicals I think those
would be those would be good additions
especially for people who have those
chemicals detected in their Wells and it
would have to be notified of them
um there's a lot of information on the
internet but there's a lot of power and
a notice that can kind of get you
started in your search uh so the bottom
line is is that I think that would be a
good addition okay a lot follow-up or a
follow-up okay thank you Mr chair so um
representative would you be willing to
work with me on an amendment because I
would like to have stronger language
around lead just because of what we've
seen on the terrible impacts to children
in their cognitive development with even
very very small amounts to lead and
additionally with pfas EPA came out last
June with a health advisory essentially
saying it was parts per quadrillion
levels anything above that is unsafe and
has Health impacts so
um would so would you be willing to work
with me on an amendment to provide some
more informative language around the
representative harved and representative
representative Vale
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking this question in your amendments
I'm a real estate transactional attorney
would you have a problem or a
recommendation regarding the effective
date
um being in the real estate industry
business I understand the seriousness of
all these issues but I'm just wondering
why the effective date wasn't asked for
January 1 2024.
again the the effective date is uh is a
leftover from uh from 667 and I can
understand why uh why uh uh 60 days uh
might not be adequate notice for the
real estate community so that would be
um that would definitely be something we
could look at in terms of an amendment
that would be great
thank you representative Vale for a
question
thank you Mr chair um thank you
representative for bringing in this bill
and for taking my question
I'm just looking at on page two line 12
where it says Roman numeral six failure
to test a well or submit the laboratory
report resulting from such Test Section
shall be a violation
um I'm sorry I do don't have the um the
the numerals I have the bill in front of
me but I have the online version which
doesn't have my numbers uh so if you
could if you could just tell me the
section Roman numeral section is um
Roman numeral six okay
thank you approximately 12 lines down
all right from the top where it says um
so my question is about
um resulting from
such Test Section shall be a violation
and I don't see where the violation is
otherwise described either in the bill
or in law
existing
so this would be on the part of the
installer of the pump who did not
perhaps oh Phil who failed to test a
foreign
does it belong in there
not whether or not it belongs in there
it just says here that there is a
violation for the failure of the of the
person who we are asking this bill is
asking to be responsible for the testing
and so if that is a violation then what
is the subsequent actions that get taken
with that violation in order for the um
the purpose of the bill to be
um a reality for the homeowner
we're talking about Representatives
heart a violation in um I know in
criminal law is not not an offense that
actually appears on your criminal record
um only misdemeanors and felonies appear
on a criminal record and I believe
uh a violation would be a penalty of up
what I am what I am what I am not 100
sure of is
um
uh enforcement of that violation and and
I and I think that might be a good uh
question for uh uh for the folks from
Des if they are here
um uh to testify to uh but the I but
essentially the idea is that failure to
do the testing should have some sort of
a consequence
um and it's an effort uh
to put uh some teeth into the bill even
anyone else
being no one from the no one else from
the committee
thank you very much
chair recognizes representative Wendy
Thomas
turn your bike on
Mr chair and members of the resource
Recreation and development committee it
is a pleasure to be back here
I am representative Wendy Thomas
representing the town of Merrimack I'm
providing testimony and support of House
Bill 205 and act relative to testing
private Wells
this bill requires the installers of new
well pumps test the water for certain
contaminants and it also requires
property buyers to be notified of the
presence of these contaminants in the
water before the property can be sold
everything on the list on page two is
known to cause ill health to humans I'm
going to focus on items p q r s and t
which are the pfas chemicals in our
fairly new additions to water testing
when a similar bill was introduced in
2020 there was some skepticism about the
need for everyone in the state to test
for pfas
legislators knew that there was a
problem on the Seacoast and in Southern
New Hampshire but they thought pfas
contamination was isolated to those
areas
it is now three years later and we know
that pfas is found virtually everywhere
it's near our landfills our corporations
near airports and fire stations it's in
our bio waste it's even been found in
our orange juice
what was thought to be an
over-exaggeration of Health impacts in
2020 has sadly proven to be prophetic
pfast in our water is not just quote an
inconvenience it is a killer responsible
for Cancers and chronic illness chronic
illnesses autistic symptoms learning
disabilities and chronic diseases like
high cholesterol and high blood sugar
all of these conditions have been linked
to pfas exposure
pfas are carcinogenic hormone and immune
disrupting and health-altering chemicals
and to purchase real estate without
knowing about their presence in the
water is a moral and unethical
to those who say this creates an undue
financial burden on the seller I assure
you the cost of chronic illness and
cancer is far greater
as long as we have pfests in our
environment as long as corporations
continue to spew pfas chemicals into our
water air and soil we will need to find
tools necessary to protect our and our
children's health
this bill gives us some protection from
exposure to chemicals and substances in
our water that that are known to harm us
for these reasons I urge you to support
House Bill 205 and to vote at OTP and
I'd also like to add to Representatives
Wolfe's comment about existing Wells
this afternoon you'll be hearing
my my bill 398 which covers exactly that
any questions by members of the
committee
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
Matt Mayberry from
good afternoon chairman
good afternoon chairman good good
afternoon Representatives I'm Matt
Mayberry I'm the Executive Vice
President of the New Hampshire Home
Builders
we are in opposition to The Spill
for a few simple reasons we already do
it
in that
in order to get a certificate of
occupancy for a new home
a builder and the installer must provide
to the municipality a water test
showing a lot of the items that you
already have presented here
are the 10 000 Wells that were tested of
the 250 000 private Wells that's only a
four percent sample
and if you look at and if you sold
property either purchased or sold on
page one
number five is water supply
and the and letter e water test has
water been tested yes or no date of the
test
if yes
make an attachment are you aware of the
test results of being unsatisfactory
with notations yes or no
our test results available and what
steps were taken to remediate the
problem
page one of any sales disclosure
I'm also a real estate broker an agent
for 35 years so I look at this from the
Builder's perspective and the Realtors
perspective and working for those buyers
what this does with the passage is it
places an undue financial burden upon
owners who don't already have a problem
you're asking 250 000 people to test
their Wells shouldn't it be the decision
of the homeowner
when does government come in and say we
know best you should do this
and it should do this versus shall do
this
the other question I have for you for
the committee is
on page two rule number six I
contaminants common and well water
most private wells in New Hampshire
provide water containing harmful
contaminants
so are you telling the 250 000
residents of New Hampshire you're Well's
contaminated
it's a statement by the state and by
policy makers that your water contains
contaminants
you did a 10 000 sample of 250 000
that's pretty presumptuous
we already do this ladies and gentlemen
I'll be brief because you hear from a
lot of folks
but the New Hampshire Home Builders we
provide a water test for new wells we
can't get a certificate of occupancy
without it
thank you uh don't go away
any questions by members of the
thank you Mr chair um thank you for
taking my question I just want to know
if we can get a copy of that
um application that you sent and to the
committee members
um
yes ma'am thank you you referenced that
we already do this this is already in
the law and if we could tell me where
that is in the law that I could it's not
law it's it's practic it's in order to
get a certificate of occupancy from a
municipality where a new home is being
built
the developer must provide a water test
to the municipality in order to get that
certificate of occupancy
and I I don't know the law ma'am and I
can certainly try to find it
thank you for taking my question
absolutely Mr chairman approached the
chairman with the seller's disclosure
sure
actually also if you maybe uh just if
you have a copy that you could email to
the committee on the yeah that would be
thank you
uh representative
Donnelly and representative wrong
thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking
um I noticed in section six again uh it
mentions that
on line 14 notification notification
required well water containments rate uh
radon lead
um and they want to amend to add in
uh arsenic mpfest
is that an amendment that is not in the
existing RSA today do you know
I know it's not on the existing selfish
disclosure that an agent provides to
buyers and sellers to complete us
um specifically with those language of
pfas is not on there okay so the pfas
language I'm sorry just real quick the
pfas language is not add on the added on
to that specific form that you just
handed to the chair correct thank you
yes ma'am
representative wrong or question thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question
um you mentioned that well water is
already tested before a certificate of
occupancy can be granted what are the
components of that test what what things
are tested in that
live is dictated by the municipality and
I can get that for you right away
representative for whatever I don't want
to forget one of them so I will get that
for you right away okay
um is the certificate a follow-up Mr
chair thank you is the
um if things during that well testing
that well water testing
um exceed some acceptable level
um what happens then to that but what
does the Builder do then they mitigate
it I'm sorry they would mitigate it okay
okay and can I have one more okay and
you also mentioned that
um during the course of a property
transfer the the seller fills out a
disclosure form have there been any
instances where a seller misrepresents a
condition or states that oh the water's
fine it's been tested when it actually
hasn't been tested and if that's the
case what's the process now that the
buyer owns the home and discovers that
the disclosure was
um was was faulty what how long does it
what did they have to do and how long
does it take to remedy that situation I
think that's why God created attorneys
oh
um but what would happen representative
in practicality is if I'm representing a
buyer okay I've done this for 35 years
as if I'm representing the buyer we're
still going to get the water tested
anyway
you know no matter what says on paper
I as a buyer agent where Council my
clients get the water tested get the
septic tested get all the tests so you
feel comfortable
because water shifts water changes you
know sometimes they may have done the
test 20 years ago and things have
changed
so it's really you know
for professional real estate agents who
work on a seller's disclosure
we worked to protect those buyers and
the sellers it helps everyone but if if
a seller lies
then that's a whole other legal
situation
representative
McGill
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question my question so if you
do discover
um problems with those well tests and
you do mitigate them like you mentioned
to what standards do you mitigate them
say if you discover pfas if you were to
discover pfast of the water
it would be done within the regulations
within New Hampshire New Hampshire
employment uh Environmental Services Des
so whatever they put forward it was to
be mitigated to come within those
standards
for the question for a follow-up
so can you can you give an example of
how that mitigation
might be done like a walk us walk us
through what sort of things might be put
in place to correct a pfas problem if
you discovered it in a well if you were
required to mitigate pfas in a
residential well
I'm not an expert in that field I don't
work in that field so it'd be
inappropriate for me to answer because I
don't have all the facts and I want to
be correct when I talk with you okay the
next person up will be speaking to that
and it will be uh Mr Kernan so great
thank you he can he can tell us all
about how to do stuff much better than
me
thank you
representative Darby
thank you Mr chair
um since you are a licensed uh realtor
as I understand it
um and I think you mentioned that this
this form that's described in you know
four or 477 4A is provided to the buyer
um and that's the language that's being
described here I'm trying to ask the
same question I asked earlier which is
you know section two of that says that
if the this statement is not provided
then there's no legal ramification
um can you describe are you aware of any
cases where the for this
um sort of notice was not provided and
if there's uh you could see any concern
where people might be less tempted to
um provide this notice if it were not uh
with the language that as it's laid out
here
I think representative take another
Direction where I think you want to go
with him please correct me if I'm wrong
when you often bought a home through
foreclosure
for instance ub-handed cellular
disclosure that says unknown unknown
unknown unknown they know nothing about
the property
at that point in time the realtor would
say to their client we should get the
water tested
or say to the bank
please test the water
so there have been times where those
things are not completed but they're not
filled in
so the consumer and to their agent
representing them
to
mitigate that exposure get the water
tested
so it it does come up sir
often in foreclosures or bank owned
properties
okay thanks
hey
anyone else
seeing no one
thank you very much thank you chairman
thank you committee members have a nice
day
uh call uh Brandon Kernan from Des I
apologize normally I yeah the the Des
person is right up after the uh uh these
the presenter of the of the bill that uh
I messed up the cards so
no problem thank you chairman I'm
Brandon Kernan I'm the administrator of
the drinking water and groundwater
Bureau at the Department of
Environmental Services and I'm here to
testify on House Bill 205 which would as
we've mentioned
um would require that when new wells are
constructed that Wells be tested for
traditional contaminants and pfas and
then when there's real estate
transactions that there'd be some
foreign language provided to buyers
about concerns about water quality and
radon you know the department does very
much strongly support educating people
about
identifying and if necessary mitigating
contaminants in their air and water I
mean it's critical
um we recognize with this bill though
where test is required for new wells it
does have costs and already to construct
a new well and install a pump it costs
about 12 to 25 000 and the testing
requirements as proposed here could add
another four to eight hundred dollars if
you do both the traditional contaminants
that people generally would look for and
then include pfast about two-thirds of
that 400 to 800 is associated with the
pfast testing it is quite expensive
you know this discussion about costs
it's really a policy question you know
we think it's important that people know
what they're drinking but you know
mandating the cost is something that I
think it's important to have a
discussion about and this very
discussion did occur back in 2020 and
the house did pass
um House Bill 667 after working really
hard on the bill with industry and
collaborating with various stakeholders
to get the language where almost
everyone can support it and so it passed
the house but unfortunately covid
disrupted the legislative session and it
never was considered in the Senate and
so that's why 667 did not go forward
you know pfas is absolutely a serious
and difficult issue for New Hampshire
especially in the southern part of the
state where hundreds of square miles of
surface water and groundwater is
contaminated due to air emissions it's
our population Center the state that's
contaminated essentially and they have
unsafe levels of pfoa above our state
standards at this point and the
statistics you heard from representative
Muse are accurate you know 30 percent
exceed our standard and 80 80 86 percent
are detectable
for that reason and still I believe
there's language on page three you know
starting at line five that talks about
the concern about pfas in the state with
an emphasis on Southern Hampshire
this statement on page three starting
line five is completely accurate and is
um but this time we don't have resources
from the people that made these
chemicals and caused our groundwater
surface water be contaminated to to pay
for private well testing I mean these
pfas shouldn't be there you know it's
very unfair that residents are left with
having to deal with the cost of sampling
and treating for it but until such time
there's resources the sample every well
from responsible parties that's where
we're at at this point
the good news as representative as
representative Muse pointed out that if
you do sample your well and you find
unsafe levels of pfas over our state
standards there is a state rebate
program to put in treatment for pfast or
to extend your water if there's an
option nearby to a public water system
so there's a benefit if you do testing
there is a remedy in place and resources
for that
and I'll just point out that if this
bill does pass you know as proposed it
would be a violation of the Safe
Drinking Water Act if the testing for
new wells or this did not occur
that enforcement of that of the century
Commodore act falls under the Department
of Environmental Services and we could
enforce it but to be reactive we
wouldn't have a Mecca mechanism in place
to make sure everyone is getting their
Wells tested when there's a new well
installed but if we had inquiries or
compliant and found that this was not
the case we would have finding Authority
that's not usually what we jump to you
usually work with an entity first to see
if they will make it right and do the
work that they well you educate them
about the law and then you work with
them to get them to complete the work
ultimately that doesn't happen there's a
range a pretty large range where fines
could be administered and you look at
things such as the severity of
infraction did they know about it ahead
of time what was the financial benefit
and there's sort of a process you go
through to come up Case by case what
that actual fine would be and if the
party wants to work out something
um you know a compromise um to make it
right so but it was a long process
before wherever we get to finding people
really try working with them first
um with that I'd be happy to answer any
questions uh
I have first off
do you have a a uh any uh documentation
any right uh any uh
anything to
other than the you know we did no
testimony or Monday but uh yes okay yeah
I know I I realized that usually usually
you do pass something out
uh
Innovative from and then rep then
representative Darby
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my questions Mr Karen no
currently
um Des does have a I believe it's in
statute that they have to inform well
owners within a certain radius of a well
that's been found to exceed state pfas
mcls is that correct that is correct
so if a new well is being drilled and
um
Diaz would they get notice of that and
what happens if that new well that's
being drilled Falls within that 500 feet
radius of a contaminated well
we would not necessarily get that
information if there was an exceedance
unless the homeowner or the pump
installer provided it to us the labs
don't automatically report exceedances
it's sort of private information at this
time the way it works someone samples
are well but it's provided to us it
would go into our our database our
online data viewer and that 500 foot
notification would kick in at that point
okay
so if if the well was already there and
shown to be contaminated
um or if the well was already there
within 500 feet DS would take action but
they you're saying that DS should not
take action on a well that hasn't
actually been drilled yet but is being
planned to being drilled
well ideally when people find elevated
levels of contaminants they would share
that data with us and many times they do
and we do act on it but there's not a
legal requirement that is you as a
private owner sample your well if you
have a exceedance you do not have to
necessarily provide that to us unless
you're aware of a release of a chemical
or something on your property that was
illegal itself but you know spills and
that kind of thing are reportable but
the actual exceedance would not be
mandated to be reported to Des okay just
one more final question Mr chair
um so what I understand from your
testimony early on you said that you
strongly support education and people's
awareness of these hazardous substances
that may be in a well but that you
um don't support the financial impact
that this bill would pose to people
because the testing would be
um
uh four hundred to eight hundred dollars
per test do you know how that price
compares to someone having to get health
treatment for any of the diseases that
are caused by pfas or these other
elements
first of all I didn't mean to come
across as not supporting the testing
mandate I think the department
acknowledges that's a broader policy
decision than it should necessarily have
a definitive answer on we definitely
think all wells should be tested for
naturally occurring contaminants and
pfas the naturally contouring
contaminants are kind of all of our own
responsibility we live in New Hampshire
It's associated with your property
unfortunately pfas it's unfair but right
now the only option really is is for the
homeowner to pay for that even though
it's not their fault that it's in the
water and we don't like that but that's
how it is
representative Darby thank you Mr chair
uh thank you for taking my question
so you mentioned that you it would be a
reactive
um that responding to the violation
would be reactive because you don't for
example know
um what the testing results would be but
um could this language in you know
um
section five on line six it says
provide the report to the property owner
could it also provide the report to Des
DS also I believe is notified of all
Wells that are drilled and then they
could correlate the tomb
yes that could be a requirement when a
well driller constructs a new well
they have to file a well-compression
report within 90 days so theoretically
this could be with that however the law
or the bill I'm sorry is proposing the
pump installer do the testing which is
appropriate because you can't test until
you have a pump and a pump might be
installed you know 120 days or 180 days
after the wells installed so you might
not be able to make the symbol at the
same time but yes you could submit it
and we could merge the two documents
together in our files in our database
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um I want to follow up on something that
representative rung had raised
um and just to clarify for my own
knowledge so right now there wouldn't be
any grants available to do any of this
testing by the
um pump installer
based in whether
there might be pfas or other chemicals
in the water
at this time there's not a Statewide
program to test Wells for pfas or
traditional contaminants we are sampling
every day private Wells or P fast
responding to contamination events where
we see a private well has an exceedance
we draw the 500 Circle do notification
with that notification for pfas we're
offering the sample to well at no cost
to the homeowner and so that's where
it's focused right now and then as
representative Muse pointed out we have
a pilot project in the Seacoast where a
number of Seacoast towns are having
private well testing events that pfas is
being included where testing can occur
at no cost and the goal of that program
which was funded by the drinking water
groundwater trust fund is a look at as a
pilot program where we'll report back to
the legislature on how a Statewide
program could be stood up to test for
both pfas and traditional contaminants
you know ideally
something like that happened with MTB
could occur where eventually responsible
parties are brought to bear the costs of
the damage they did and pay for the cost
of sampling Wells and ideally that's
what we do to address this problem is
this shouldn't be in our groundwater
thank you thank you
representative harp for our question
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um prior speaker was asked Can you
comment on the methods of a remediation
if the well Test shows pfas for a
homeowner
yes there's
basically three approaches for treating
pfast and there'll be more as we go
forward because there's a lot of focus
on it the most common method if you want
to treat all the water in your house so
from the well going into your house
would be granule activated carbon and
that can cost a few thousand to six
thousand dollars to remove pfast and all
the water and then of course you have to
maintain it and replace it over time
that only removes pfast though and it
doesn't address the natural contaminants
for the most part the metals go right
through the carbon
another option is just to treat water at
your kit in the kitchen so you put a
little device either in your basement
with little hoses that go up to your
countertops or underneath your sink and
you can treat your kitchen faucet or the
refrigerator water and or the
refrigerator water with what we call
point of view so most of the house
doesn't have treated water but where you
drink the water or use it for cooking is
treated and you could do carb in there
or reverse osmosis and reverse osmosis
only works at that small scale within
the kitchen because you waste a lot of
water to make clean water but that
actually takes care of most of the
natural contaminants in addition to
pfast so that's a really good choice and
that costs generally about a thousand
dollars if you pay somebody or if you do
okay anyone else oh by the way it's one
representative Darby Roberta first thank
you very briefly um so section T
um on of the contaminants to be tested
for says other per and poly basically
pfas that Des finds
um concerning in the future
is is there any concern that that might
be open-ended and lead to increases in
testing costs in the future
I don't think so I mean the way it works
right now there's two standard methods
to test for pfas and depending on if you
use one or the other it's you know 25 to
say 37 compounds that can be looked for
under the two methods and you can save a
little bit of money by asking the lab to
only report four of this of the whole
set but you don't save a lot the labs
are set up to run the whole method
because that's what and that's what
we're requiring and that's what water
systems are often doing so I I think as
we find out more about pfas and if we
adopt additional standards it'll just
work into the process as a matter of
adding another chemical standard into
the analytical process
moving whoops
moving right along uh supporting the
bill Dan Grace from New Hampshire water
turn it on there it is uh Dan Grace
um I'm in the well industry I was active
with House Bill 667 when we first put it
through
um I'm here on behalf of the New
Hampshire water well Association which
is a membership of all of our peers in
the industry I've been an active
president for I think eight years so
I've gotten a lot of collective
information from other folks doing what
we do and I guess the whole idea of this
bill really is to just create a standard
um
as it was talked about earlier that
towns municipalities do require water
testing but some of those requirements
are as low as a coliform uh E coli
bacteria test and what we've found is
many many customers
call us and say something's wrong with
my water and they don't notice until
they see aesthetic staining from a
secondary like iron or manganese and
they say but our water tests passed so
when when a lack of better return naive
homeowner buys a house and is told their
water passed they think it's safe to
drink we go in we look for the water
test none was collected other than a
standard bacteria test so we do a
complete comprehensive test the 14
parameter test that's recommended on
this bill
and find that there's elevated arsenic
uranium radon you know other carcinogens
but they were under the safety blanket
that their water was safe to drink
because it passed the water test that
required to see the co
so we're just trying around the corners
and protect health and and human safety
to get more people to test this this 14
parameter test the addition to pfas um
the association is not uh for at this
point
um we don't feel that the testing is
fluent enough
um
it's it's a six to eight week lag and
getting those results back there's one
New Hampshire lab that does the testing
a lot of these samples are overnighted
um after collection to get to outsourced
Labs
um I I just think there needs to be a
refined sense of of testing before we
get it locked into a bill so the
association is in favor of of this bill
house 205 but actually removing the
pfaster requirement and just using that
um map that Des has created online as a
indicator to recommend to customers
where to test water now out of the 10
000 Wells that were tested and 87 came
back with pfasa I'm not sure where those
Wells were tested if they were all
tested in the contamination Zone
obviously you're going to have a skewed
number then if you did it brought across
the entire State now my office operates
from Canadian border all the way down to
the mass border we have three locations
we've tested a lot for pfas in in those
areas and and have really come up with
very few indications of of pfas in the
walls that we've drilled so adding this
to every well that we drilled we just
saw is cumbersome for the homeowners
um it's expensive it's time consuming
and we don't know if the technology is
there yet we'd like to get this bill
through uh you know as as a 14 parameter
test just creating a standard for every
new well that's drilled in the state so
we have something to go on and something
to start this off
any questions by members of the
committee
uh
is it Joanne McIntyre from New Hampshire
Realtors
good morning I'm Joni McIntyre I work as
a real estate agent for Coldwell Banker
J Hampe Associates here in Concord and
I'm president-elect of the New Hampshire
Association of Realtors
um in the legislation if the legislation
if the legislator chooses to move
forward with House Bill 205 then
Realtors would like to see some changes
to the language I'd like to say first of
all our goal as a realtor is to inform
our clients
and not frighten them
um the first change on page two line 21
related to the changes to RSA 4774a
this reads most private Wells I mean
most private Wells contain harmful
contaminants
Realtors would suggest that this
language is altered to private Wells may
contain harmful contaminants in our
discussion with Des as well as our
general knowledge
with buyers and sellers it is not
accurate to say that most private Wells
contain harmful contaminants in it's
important that we be precise with our
language to ensure that our buyers make
informed decisions
on page 3 line 21 through 23 we strongly
oppose this this provision
when personally when I receive
information that contains bold
capitalized text my understanding is
that this highlighted section is the
most important data that I've received
in the case in this case it implies that
radon lead arsenic's Arsenic and PFS and
pfaffs are the most important factors in
um the Realtors Supply buyers with ant
sellers with five pages of disclosures
which you just received and a five-page
pns which has currently the the
um radon lead arsenic
description
um
but it also contains language about
water sewer air quality
um Insurance flood insurance
easements covenants just a gazillion
things
all of these factors are important some
of them are more important than others
and I don't mean to trivialize
trivialize the pfaffs but for some
people a buyer moving to Hopkinton who
has half a dozen chickens the pfas
information is important to them
but it's really important to them to be
in a neighborhood that does not have
covenants prohibiting chickens so we
want to make sure that there's nothing
that says this stuff is more important
um because for our buyers there's a
myriad of things that are really
in terms of new p-pass in terms of the
new pfas testing requirement in section
one of the bill as well as the new pfas
notification requirement inserted into
RSA 477a we will defer to your better
judgment however these tests are not
inexpensive and Realtors are keenly
aware of pfaff's contamination in and
around Merrimack this testing
requirement will be Statewide adding
several hundred dollars
to to a well drill is probably fine for
most of us
but you should know that it can be a
prohibitive burden for some of the
residents you need to weigh mandating a
500 to 700 expense in areas where pfaps
may not have been a demonstrated problem
similarly
we are certainly not opposed to new
pfaff's language in RSA 477a
however
we do think it's important to remind the
legislature that
that the long longer the notification
section becomes the less likely buyers
are going to be to read it I don't know
if you've ever heard of tmtr my son sent
me that when I send them a long email
too much to read and that really does
happen I have occasions where where a
buyer or even a seller will say to me
Joni when is our closing date that is on
your that is on your pns and they
haven't really read it so we want to be
careful not to make those disclosures so
long that they don't read them
um
so again we leave it to you to best
judge if pfas chemicals pose a similar
threat statewise and finally
um we would ask that if this does pass
it does the it would take effect on 1 1
24. this will give us time to inform our
members about the change educate them
about the issue and incorporate it into
our into our forms
thank you thank you uh do you have
copies of your suggestions uh
it would be a lot easier for members of
this committee to or or anyone to put in
a
amendments if we if we didn't have to
complement write them all down listening
to you can I send them can I email them
yeah oh yeah fine mail uh email it to
the committee okay great thank you
any questions by members of the
committee
seeing none
Jody gremlis
representing the American chemistry
Council suggestions for an amendment
that for or against yeah thank you Mr
chairman members of the committee I
received these comments from the
American chemistry Council yesterday so
I'm a little bit I don't have it all
polished for you yet but I will also
take that advice of putting this in
writing and sending it to the committee
the chemistry council is a national
trade Association representing
chemistries Plastics manufacturers in
these in the United States including
members here in New Hampshire but I will
note not saying Cobain they are not a
member of the association our members
are committed to the safety of the
products and the production of Public
Health
we're not focused on the policy being
um included or being proposed in this in
this bill we're just really looking at
the Amendments we'd like to suggest
focus on the testing and Reporting on
those pfas um for which Des already has
that process
um you know through the EPA and through
the administrative process that Des has
pfas are a very large class of
substances with a wide variety of
physical and chemical properties and so
not all pfas are actually the ones that
are problematic like we've seen in the
various P foa pfas et cetera Etc so I
would just make two comments and I'll
put this in writing so that you'll have
it on page two
um line
uh it's it's a little little paragraph T
where the section talks about other per
and polyflorically fluorical substances
for which Des Services establish an MCL
pursuant to 45 an ambient groundwater
quality standard adopted Persona to 485c
we would stop the sentence there the
other language about detect and reported
to Des and other Wells within the same
Community we just want to make sure that
the testing and the reporting stays the
way that it currently does now through
the department that would be our first
suggestion our second suggestion would
be on page three
um line 12. starting with that last
sentence all per and polyflorical
substances associated with the with the
testing method should be reported we
would suggest language such as levels of
pifoa pfos pfna
pfhxs and other pfas for which the
department has established mcl's
pursuant to 45 or ambient ground quarter
groundwater quality standard percent of
45C should be reported so we were just
kind of like to see the language on
testing and Reporting stay with what the
department has currently and those are
the only suggestions we would make again
the policy is up to you
and I would be happy to put this in
writing and send it to you so if you
have a subcommittee you'll have that to
consider thank you is there any
questions by members of the uh
committee
thank you see you none thank you and
good morning morning Sharon renzullo and
honorable members of the committee
I'm Nancy Murphy from Hillsboro 12. I
represent Merrimack of a community of
about 28 000 people which has been
highly impacted by pfas we're currently
dealing with an exceedance of kidney
cancer cases that are known to be
associated with pfas exposure so this
bill isn't particularly important to me
I'm here in support of HB 205 that I see
much like both a consumer protection and
an informed consent bill
um an additional cost of four to eight
hundred dollars to include pfas testing
I would suggest is money very well spent
the cost to individuals and Society to
deal with the negative Health impacts
associated with these toxic chemicals
far exceeds that amount
I believe new homeowners should receive
full disclosure as to what contaminants
are present in the well water as
knowledge is power homeowners who are
informed about the levels of pfas in
their Wells that will provide their
drinking water will help protect
themselves and their families from the
health impacts known to be associated
with these toxic chemicals
three quarters of a small amount of of
private Wells tested thus far showed the
presence of pfas and about a third of
them have pfas levels that exceed
current state standards we must keep in
mind that current New Hampshire pfas
mcls far exceed that which would be
reflective of the epa's recently
released recommendations regarding
levels that are considered quote safe
and that Health advisory level for at
least one of those chemicals is four
parts per quadrillion which is pretty
it's less far less than one I'm
supportive of any Amendment um that
would make be more specific to the
negative Health impacts of arsenic radon
and Lead as though I know in Merrimack
we too have elevated lead levels in our
Public Schools whether that's through
faucets pipes or whatever it's important
for people to know because of the health
impacts of that as well
um I I just wanted to say that um no
pfas and we have no other at least 12
000 of them right now
um no pfest have been determined safe so
I think any suggestion that they are
safe or we only have to worry about some
um it would would be of great concern to
me
um I would also suggest that we remember
that the American chemistry Council uh
represents the manufacturers of pfest
um Statewide assistance is available
right now for reimbursement to uh well
owners that meet the Criterion which is
the exceedance of of mcls and other
things so
um it's you know having a um that rebate
to help install filtration if you find
that your uh your drinking water exceeds
the current mcls is certainly a benefit
um thank you for your time and attention
and I ever urge you to vote OTP on HB
205 thank you thank you any questions by
members of the committee
seeing none thank you very much
that's it for the uh
or with pink cards
I will close the hearing on
I'll spill 205.
and open the hearing on House Bill 214.
relative to limitations on the
designation of a portion of the
thank you Mr chair and I will be
submitting my my pink card for the
record my name is representative
Rosemary rung from Hillsborough 12 which
is the town of Merrimack
um last year I happened upon a work
Committee of uh resources and learned
the of the need to
amend or modify a current statute which
um presently puts a lot of restrictions
on water removal from the Merrimack
river and when that statute was first
drafted it its intent was to protect the
water from unnecessary withdrawals and
just uh to you uh establish that as a
protection of the river but we've since
learned that those restrictions hamper
the flexibility of communities to
respond to water quality issues that
that they may encounter and I'll bring
up pfas as one example and the
Department of Environmental Services
asked for this this bill so that it
gives them more flexibility to respond
to water quality issues that may require
withdrawal from the river as you'll hear
from the Department
this bill will not affect and and will
not create any risk or damage to the
Merrimack River it's just to give the
department more flexibility in being
able to address
and be able to provide for any instances
that come up that will require
withdrawal to ensure the health and
safety of the public
I am not going to accept any questions
on this because I know that Mr Ted deers
is here from Des and he's the expert on
that so if you do have any questions if
thank you very much Mr chair committee
for the record my name is Ted dears I'm
the assistant director of The Water
Division at the New Hampshire Department
of Environmental Services and uh it's a
it's a pleasure to be here with you this
morning still morning uh this afternoon
sorry
um I'm uh I'm the one who's sitting
between you and lunch so I'm not going
to say a whole lot of words
um except to thank uh representative
wrong I think she uh
she introduced this bill perfectly uh it
leads us into where this bill is really
headed what I would like to do is to
spend just
a couple seconds talking about the
rivers management and protection program
before I jump in
uh the rivers management Protection
Program has been around since about 1998
1988 and it has
um what it does is it sets up a local
process for people to nominate Rivers
for the special factors that that that
really make those uh the characteristics
that make those Rivers special
and so this has happened on 19 rivers
around the state and when that happens
they create a local advisory committee
which serves as the eyes and ears for
Des in their communities
they are they're afforded a certain
number of new protections on those
particular bodies of water
and it opens up a dialogue between the
local folks who really care about these
rivers and the state uh both from a
resource perspective as well as from a
regulatory perspective
so it's been a great program it's been
very successful over the years
um I have uh that I'll pass out to you
here in a second some a little bit of a
little graphic that's sort of a by the
Numbers kind of graphic that I think it
illustrates well the success of this
this language that you see in front of
you in House Bill 214
was the original language that
designated the Merrimack river which is
one of the first five rivers into the
program uh the lower Merrimack river in
this case uh in 1990
at that time and and I started working
on in-stream Flow and River protection
issues not long after this time
at that time there was concern about the
quantity of water in the Merrimack River
there was an EPA initiative that was
going on at the time that was really
looking at sort of this Bi-State river
that we have it starts in New Hampshire
and and ends in Massachusetts
that there was a lot of concern about
water quantity and what was going to
happen over time with increasing
population
the forecasts uh for growth the forecast
for how much water would be consumed all
of that was pointing towards potential
problems in the future
so when they initially went through and
did this designation there was concern
about the the water withdrawals that
pennichuck was doing in the lower part
of the Merrimack that provide water to
their service area which includes you
know areas around Nashville that that
part
so this language was put in and this was
long before uh the state had figured out
kind of how are we going to address
water withdrawals from surface waters
and how are we going to do that in a way
that won't dewater rivers and and lets
us be able to have a sustainable system
over time our
program the river's protect Protection
Program the in-stream flow program the
water quality certification program all
of these are approaches at DES
which allow us to have considerable more
sophistication than we had in 1990 as to
how we look at Water withdrawals
we now have adequate we believe that we
have adequate
process adequate ability for the public
to have input and adequate science to be
able to dress issues wherever they form
representative wrong also mentioned the
challenges with water supply in the
southern part of the state
the challenges of mtbe and pfas just
some towns have unfortunate geology they
just don't have the kind of water they
need to support their their population
all of this points towards this
regionalization that's going on which is
tremendously exciting one of the most
exciting things that's happened in water
in a long time here in New Hampshire
this opportunity to regionalize and to
be able to make sure that people have
the water where they need it clean water
so what we'd like this book really comes
out of a bill that happened in the last
session uh in which
um the bill did not go forward but
this conversation came up and there
wasn't time in the last session to
address this issue but I think that
there was consensus around the committee
that this was an important thing to do
to make sure that there's the
flexibility to for the future to ensure
that we have adequate water supply when
we need it and where we need it
so I'm going to stop there and just see
if people have any questions and
um I have written testimony and
unfortunately I left it on my printer
and my printer would not fit in my car
so I was unable to bring it with me but
I will uh you've been it's been emailed
to you and I will bring over uh copies
for you to have next time you meet so
thank you very much for your time and
I'm happy to answer any questions you
might have
thank you any questions by members of
the committee
uh I'll I'll allow it because you
actually were just putting it in for him
oh thank you Mr chair normal conditions
I wouldn't okay thank you no I just want
to
um bring to the attention of the
committee that I do believe that we did
receive a letter from commissioner
Robert Scott supporting this bill
or a question
representative Darby
thank you Mr chairman brief super brief
question representative wrong mentioned
that
um you know the the limit on the amount
of water that could be withdrawn
um affected um how to respond to water
quality issues and I was wondering if
you could give us some examples of that
yeah so I think
um thank you for the question I
appreciate that and I'm sorry I can't I
can't I'm going to back up just a little
bit and see if I can actually see you as
I'm answering your question
I I think one of the again this sort of
I want to point towards the southern uh
the sort of Southern New Hampshire Water
Project that's brought water down from
Manchester down uh all the way into
Salem and and throughout that that lower
area
the one of the reasons for that was the
failure of wells and again some some
what I call unfortunate geology uh is
that there are a number of communities
that just don't have kind of good access
to good volumes of water
so so as we've looked at those
opportunities
um there are a lot of different ways in
which that can manifest itself as
different communities want to try to
improve their water supply join in on
some of these Regional approaches
we all are familiar at this point with
the challenges of of pfas in places like
Merrimack in places like Litchfield
in other parts of the southern part of
that Southern Tier
that could eventually it may become more
cost effective to actually hook some of
those communities and smaller water
systems and individual uh you know
streets up to public water supplies for
places you just heard a bill on on
private Wells so you know that's a place
in which you if you had a whole bunch of
private wells in a certain area you
might want to try to plumb all that
in order to do that you would may need
additional water supply
so the way we kind of look at this is
that that may be an opportunity that you
might want to reach towards surface
waters in order to provide some of that
water supply to to those future
expansions of those systems that will
deal with things like pfas and other
problems in them so we can't imagine
today exactly what that looks like
we know that the the pennichuck right
now is is withdrawing somewhere between
you know eight and and 15 or so million
gallons a day out of the Merrimack so
they don't even they're not bumping up
against this as a limit today
but there's no other legislation like
this that I'm aware of in state law
and the other thing is is to remember
that these aren't necessarily what we
call consumptive losses
so when you're taking water out of a
river you're using it you're treating it
you're putting it back in the river
you're not consuming all of that water
are there losses sure some of those
losses are to groundwater which
eventually makes it back to the
Merrimack River anyway
um even if it's going to septic systems
it's still making its way into the into
the whole Regional water system uh
that's bringing that water back to
whence it came
so this this idea that somehow you would
sort of put this arbitrary limit which
is completely arbitrary
um on one particular water supply in one
particular location given what we know
today
um
it seems odd
does that does did I get to the point of
your question I'm sorry if I wandered
around too much yeah that was perfect
thank you thank you
any other questions by members of the
committee
seeing none thank you very much thank
you all very much have a good day I have
no other pink cards uh no one wish to
speak otherwise I will declare
the hearing on how speed house bill
214 as a jerk has has ended and that's
it for lunch you know I'll have uh we'll
we'll
be meeting at one o'clock
where we will resume
thank you Mr chair and thank you members
of the committee I'm happy to be with
you all this afternoon and hope you had
a great lunch
my name is representative Jessica Grill
and I'm introducing this bill on behalf
of Kat McGee
um this bill was filed in response to a
constituent's concern that New Hampshire
was not paying attention to adequate
water supply in sight planning for new
housing developments as a member of the
Hollis Zoning Board of adjustments
um Kat McGee's concerns have been proven
correct unfortunately and HB 310 seeks
to remedy this oversight
water has long been a commodity that
we've been able to take for granted and
sadly this is no longer the case in New
Hampshire in many instances even in a
state as rich as water as New Hampshire
we're seeing water tables evaporating
and great ponds with their first ever
algae blooms due to warming conditions
we were surprised to learn that there is
no requirement on the state level for a
certified hydrologist to be engaged in
confirming whether a site is capable of
providing adequate water to new homes
yet this very essential characteristic
of housing affects the sale and resale
value of properties as well as the
habitability of the property
I believe you'll be hearing some
examples today as of how residents and
surrounding neighborhoods are also
affected when insufficient planning is
done to address the water supply in a
given area
our initial request
um from this constituent took us through
a few twists and turns we were lucky to
receive Insight from Brandon Kernan of
the Department of Environmental Services
Water Division
um providing some information about the
history of this topic in New Hampshire
he is a professional hydrologist and has
deep knowledge of Prior State efforts
and had a great understanding of where
appropriate remedies can be applied in
the statute
for example OLS chose the conveyance of
Realty statute to make these requested
changes but the Department of
Environmental Services says that a
requirement to include water planning
and a site plan would more likely be
made under Public Safety and land use
regulations
um with this being said
um
this bill might need amending for that
reason and we ask that the resources
committee consider forming a working
group to secure additional input from
the Department of Environmental Services
um
to get an update on the books as
um how the need for housing stock
increases and developers seek to meet
that need
we were unable to secure an amendment
prior to representative McGee going on
medical leave but we would also like to
request that if the committee does
decide to advance the bill as is
um
that it modified line four to read
developers planning to build more than
four houses shall include in their site
plan a water capacity plan for the area
that takes into consideration
the information from the analysis would
still be in the hands of local planning
boards to do with what they decide at
the local level so this does not impact
any of the municipal actions that would
be taken however this bill requires that
that information be secured so that it
is available for review
questions by any members of the
committee
seeing none
thank you very much uh chair recognizes
uh Robert Clegg representing the New
thank you Mr chairman
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Robert Clegg I'm
not only
representing the home builders I'm also
a member
and I'm also a developer
and what I can say that first thoughts
on this bill is
if you pass this there'll be no more
Workforce housing the cost of a
hydrologist and whether or not the
information is correct
is far too much to ever be able to
develop and produce Workforce housing
we'll tell you that the other problem
you would have is every developer would
go in
chop up the Lots check aboard them so
that they can
not have to deal with the four Lots if
you look up at what happened at the
Lakes from Winnipesaukee Squam Lake
that's exactly what happened they check
about it everything
so you're not going to be able to do it
because people want to be able to to
afford a house
Builders want to build them but if you
put something like this in place
can't afford it it's gotten to the point
where we can't really afford to do the
houses an affordable house ended up
being five hundred thousand dollars
because of all the increases in fees
in in in in materials
and in things that the local towns asked
you to do such as school roads and
things that they never do
I will tell you that I know for a fact
that the water level can be changed
simply by taking out a beaver dam
if the beaver dam is not on your
property there's nothing you can do
you're allowed to do it
and within three years you will find
what used to be wet is not
I've also seen water flow change
by the simple use of dynamite
I've seen a well that was called the
live well
and the guy across the street blasted
for his foundation
and that live wall now ended at his lot
and that water never came across the
street
so there's nothing a report can really
tell you and there's nothing a report
can show you that yes okay there's
enough water for everybody and then
somebody puts in a garden
and starts using an excessive amount of
water
so all of those things change
most of us see this as nothing more than
a measure
in towns that don't want a lot of
Workforce housing
it's a way to keep it out because if
this was in my town we wouldn't build
if it was in Hollis we wouldn't build
I guarantee you Nash was not going to
adopt anything like this because Nashua
actually wants us
to build housing that people can afford
this will take that away
is as I said
I'm a developer and I've been doing
building since I was 15. I'm 68.
so I've been in it a long time and I can
tell you some things work some things
don't this will never work nobody will
ever comply but people like me aren't
going to bother to try to subvert the
entire law by by only building three
lots and selling the next lots to my
kids and then building three more it
just it's not worth my time anymore but
I know that if you want to start housing
the people that we need to fill the work
positions
don't do this
thank you Mr chairman
thank you questions by any members of
representative harp
thank you for taking my question you
mentioned that the cost would be too
much what is the average cost for a
hydrologist test
as far as we know we can't get anybody
for less than fifteen thousand dollars
to even look at the project
that's what our our
initial search is set
and they're not guaranteeing that it
would go it would depend on how much
detail they would actually have to put
and they also said that they'll offer no
guarantees so if I take their report and
I say here's what it is the question
then becomes according to my insurance
agent are you responsible if the
seeing no one thank you very much
uh chair calls uh Brandon Kernan
thank you I'm Brandon Kernan the
ministrator of the drinking water and
groundwater Bureau at the Department of
Environmental Services
um here's testify on House Bill 310
which would require two things one that
if you have a subdivision more than it's
gonna have more than four homes that you
complete a hydrologic analysis ensure
there's an adequate water supply and
then two that you also assess for the
occurrence of pfas we just talked about
quite a bit in House Bill 205
we department does have concerns with
the bill as proposed but we do recognize
that this topic is important and this is
an opportunity to sort of discuss and
collaborate with stakeholders on how we
can address concerns where there are
some
our comments on the bill are on the back
of the testimony letter that I just
passed out are
before we got to this hearing we did
engage with the sponsor and provided a
pretty detailed email on how we see the
concern about new development and
adequate water supply could be addressed
and so we have a very detailed email
even with a model regulation that we
were able to provide the sponsor it's
not included but I'm happy to forward
that email to anyone that's interested
the reason why we have so much work on
this topic is about 12 years ago the
legislative groundwater commission which
was in place from about 2002 to 2010
wanted to look at this like what's the
what's the impact of lots of private
Wells on the area water supply and what
can be done and what the commission
found back then not the es for the
commission was that to a large degree
existing local not State subdivision and
site plan review authorities would allow
municipality would enable them to
address concerns if they had them and
then the commission went on to look at
the statute and how it could be tweaked
to even clarify that more and so that's
the nature of the email that I provided
the sponsor a very detailed analysis of
those existing land use statutes and
where tweaks could be made to clarify it
you know we do agree that any effort to
address this topic belongs under land
use planning or public health and some
towns are already doing that requiring
studies where they have concerns
in our experience Statewide and I've
been with the state for 23 years I'm
only aware of a few instances where
there's been a development in a very
localized area town so not town-wide a
very localized area where you had a
clusters of homes that had a water
quality or quantity problem you know
three to five times I can think about
that occurring and so it's important
that you know towns being able to do
this but have a basis for doing it for
certain areas of town because as Senator
cleggs mentioned
it is a costly study and you would see
that if you see the model regulation the
groundwater commission developed um
to do a meaningful hydrogeo study to see
if you have a valuable water supply you
actually have to go and drill Wells and
pump them and see how multiple Wells
that you might use in the future
interact with each other and what their
yields are if they're sustainable
there's no amount of desktop study that
could tell you you know if there's
adequate water supply in a given area so
it is important that this is able to be
done where needed but not State
Statewide
you know relative to pfas I think for
the most part I can reference my
testimony in hospital 205 to save time
it's a serious issue it's an important
issue for the state and some of the
education or possibly testing
requirements depending which way the
committee wants to go would be probably
the way to address that versus require
an upfront study
for this bill I'd be happy to answer any
questions
any any questions by representative
Darby
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so um do you know if
there is a rule in place that allows
municipalities to require this um prior
to you know provide you know issuing a
building permit
we're we're aware of
examples where towns have used their
subdivision Authority or site plan
review regulations to build in
requirements for water supply studies to
make sure the proposed land use is
compatible with the proposed development
generally they have a basis for that
regulation usually in their master plan
where they've identified an area that
might warrant that it's just not a
trivial thing that's required by
everybody but if you have it's usually a
hillside development one Hill that has
lots of homes on it that might have
untreatable water the iron so high or
you may not have viable quantity but
again those are very few circumstances
but those that's what I'm aware of at
this point and then again the email I
could send you which is a lot of
information shows the statutes
highlights where we think the authority
is but then also shows where you could
clarify it more if you wanted to do so
I think that'd be great thank you
any uh any other questions by members of
the committee
oh oh bye hey
I know you
representative healing
the only question I have is that it uh
we found out it was very costly again
you said you had to draw quite well
what's the time frame on a study like
and you know I think I mean
theoretically it could be done in a
month or practically speaking you're
probably talking six to nine months to
to line up contractors have site layouts
or where Wells would go drill the wells
temporarily set them up with pumps do
the pumping work collect the data
process the data and write the report
yeah those things tend to take over
several months even though theoretically
it could be done in a short period of
time
take any other questions from members of
the committee I have one uh
uh Mr Clegg uh put uh mentioned a cost
associated with doing uh
with doing this kind of study is what he
said is that
within the ballpark it says he said
fifteen thousand or something like that
I actually think it could be quite a bit
higher especially because it could
involve half in the drill the wells out
of time which might be costs that you
spend later on if you go ahead with the
development but it would be cost that
would be sunk if you didn't okay 2012 be
12 to 25 000 you'd maybe drill half the
wells to test them and then
hydrogeologists would probably build out
a hundred and fifty dollars an hour and
then you'd have to have the temporary
pumps installed and people manning the
pump test and measuring so I think it
could be fifty hundred thousand dollars
potentially
to do field work some towns have done a
desktop study where you draw a circle
and say this is how much rain you get
this is how much water is going to be
taken and here's the water budget but
that really doesn't tell you how the
water occurs underground and if the
wells will be viable and interact in a
in a contentious way with one another
any other questions
and members of the committee
a
representing a representative
thank you Mr chairman
um so if I understand you correctly in
your view in the Department's view many
of the aspects in this bill are
addressed in other bills the pfas item
the pfas item is certainly addressed in
205 where it would you either require
testing or at least educate about the
importance of testing that could address
the occurrence part of it as far as
water quantity we think existing law
largely gives towns sometimes have
acquired these kind of studies already
with existing law and existing law could
be tweaked if people wanted to clarify
it even more so that these studies are
needed but again it should only really
be focused on areas where you have known
problems this is something you wouldn't
want to require of every development
everywhere because we a few and far
between examples versus kurd but where
it has occurred it's a real people feel
stranded they're earns 600 000 homes
with no viable water supply
follow up thanks Mr chairman so are are
there other other ways
to address it like I've read about
inline pumps and things like that other
ways to address those issues existing
problems or
yeah
right so this question is there a way to
address existing homes that have no
water right now or no
um
you know other than this than this
specific legislation
you talked about people who are stranded
in 600 000 homes with
lack of water supply
yeah so were you talking about low water
pressure or what were you where we were
what were you referring to both I'm
aware of developments where people
drilled multiple thousand foot Wells
that don't produce viable water supply
and then I'm aware of a couple instances
where neighborhoods have exceedingly
High irons of high levels of iron and
manganese that essentially needs uh
public water system type treatment
system and not a system that goes in
your basement that you typically have
but again that's just a handful they and
that's based on a couple decades of
experience in this area
anyone else
representative wrong
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question I'm in receiptment
that was drafted by
um representative McWilliams and her
change is uh would amend the
introductory paragraph where it says
developers planning to build more than
four houses in a subdivision she's
including the words or site plan
um so does that inclusion
um how does that impact the Department's
uh position on this bill
so
the Department's position in this bill
is that
it's intent is well placed and what it's
trying to accomplish is needed in a few
areas but it needs to be accomplished in
a whole nother statute that you can't
sweep the words here that needs to be in
public health or land use planning
statutes
and both those statutes to a large
degree we feel already enabling
municipalities to do the things this
bill wants to do
but we provided the sponsor additional
once one we highlighted that those
statutes and two we provide additional
language where it could fortify people's
understanding that they have this
Authority and then three we went as far
as to provide a model regulation that
the towns could Implement
um for those very localized areas we
have known problems and again we have
all these materials not because we did
it as an agency but the groundwater
commission from the legislature 12 years
ago asked us to do it so it's not
necessarily Des product it's not our
website it's a remnant of that
commission okay thank you
any other questions by members of the
committee
mark
thank you chair Mr Cushing floor is
yours Bart Cushing
um I saw you all last week at this time
um I represent New Hampshire water well
board that's appointed Board of
Contractors State people uh con and
citizen member that oversees the
industry I'm past president of New
Hampshire water well drillers
Association New England well drillers
Association yeah yeah but biggest thing
is I'm here actually because of my kids
and our industry
um my kids are we got two kids that are
with me
um we employ 23 people from New
Hampshire local contractor we drove
throughout the state we're headquartered
in Keene but the reason I'm here is
because of my kids quite frankly and
this this bill has concerns as the one
last week about the viability of our
industry and about the viability of our
trade
um
we Supply the wells and pumps and
maintenance to properties that this
would apply to
um
the the few areas of the state that do
have water quantity problems don't
warrant this regulation
now we do work on a lot of hydro
geologic studies we drill the wells we
do the pump testing we do the monitoring
right now currently we just got done
doing a well for a town and it was a
year in the planning process small town
Enfield you're in the planning process
they've drilled the well they've still
have not done the pump tests they will
have to do a hydrogeologic study
extensive quantity in quality testing
for experience for a long period of time
they'll be lucky if they hook that well
up in the two-year and they're in a
emergency situation we have the same
thing going on in Beau in a emergency
situation we just did one in South where
emergency situation from start to finish
before they hook these up it's two years
this requirement for just four lot
subdivision they want a hydrogeologic
study they want water quantity and
quality testing it's easy to see two
years this testing that we're doing on
these other jobs one of the people
involved said well we just paid a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars to
drill a well we don't even know we can
hook up well our part of it was about
thirty five thousand but the other parts
was fees testing engineering
Etc so the cost that this would put on
on just four Lots
and better is a good hundred grand easy
to see if they want to drill the wells
in that that they could use later on
they have to have the septic systems all
done so in the site planning say where's
the lot lines where's the septic I
didn't notice in here where they said
does this mean all lots of one acre or
less two acres or less or like I'm on
our local planning board we just
approved a subdivision of four lots and
each of the Lots at around seven and a
half to eight Acres so there's no size
requirements of this realizing that the
water in New Hampshire is localized and
it also when you use most of the water
it goes back into the ground it's not
like you pump the water out and it goes
away like a large groundwater withdrawal
for Poland Springs we're shipping it to
Wisconsin or New York City Etc the water
comes from the well goes in the Disposal
system it percolates into the ground and
it's replenished so applying this to the
whole state it's I think it's extremely
onerous and costly the data does not
support this of the I think there's
around two to three thousand Wells
drilled a year some years or a lot more
some years or less the data does not not
support this as Mr Kernan just said
um
maybe I think it should be a local
requirement as far as the PFA pfos I
think that's going to be addressed again
at our next hearing it's been addressed
this morning it's an emerging chemical
just like we had with Arsenic and radon
the standards one month or one thing
next month they're another thing and
then now with the with the PFA pfos they
started out with one contaminant one to
four now it's six now they're telling us
there's 12 000. we have no
infrastructure for testing much like
when radon came the radon tests were
extremely expensive you could only send
them to lab in Colorado it was very
onerous the standard went from ten
thousand to two thousand to seventy five
hundred to four thousand five thousand
each of our abutting states are
different
um so I I think that one really needs to
go back in the percolator about the
about the testing for PFA pfos but the
bottom line I guess should say from our
vantage point and the future of my
children who are in this business and
our industry and for the building
affordable housing I don't see this as
warranted at all four Lots it's a very
small threshold no lot size small
threshold and in our rural part of New
Hampshire where I live I live over in
the Monadnock region the only thing that
will do is really encourage any
development will be on long lines
meaning from Municipal wall sources
you know from conquered water bow water
Etc
that that's my comments and I I hope
you'd you know I hope I've been helpful
any questions by members of the
committee
yes
thank you
and thank you for taking my question
um
what do you think we could do to ensure
that
um
people aren't
buying a property and there's no
guarantee you know there's no water I
mean how often does that come up and
what do you think we could do about that
and in our area we have an area and I'll
say Chesterfield
um where we know that they have low
yielding Wells places in Walpole every
well contractor knows his local area so
much like requirement that's come forth
when you go to buy a house that you will
have a water quality test a water
quantity test would not be out of line
in requesting that and many lenders do
ask for it and the problem is in water
quantity much like testing the devils
and the details now on average we know
because we we run also water
conditioning outfit we go and test
people's water we know how many gallons
per day they use and generally speaking
a residential house we use easily less
than 300 gallons per day GPD
remembering that one gallon per minute
when I go drill a well for you I said
great we got water I got one gallon a
minute and you look at me not very happy
and you think I just put this gallon jug
on your table and said that's how much
water you got to deal with today
well there's 1440 minutes in a day
theoretically that well can generate
1440 gallons in a day does that meet the
300 gallon threshold yes it does easily
so in New Hampshire under the water well
board we've come up with fact sheets and
it's nice because we work
collaboratively with the Des they said
well people ask us what's an adequate
volume of water so we've come up with
standards that says a Wells a certain
number deep has X number gallons per
minute but essentially it says if a well
can make 600 gallons per day that that
is a adequate water supply
now does that cover I want to have a hot
tub
I like to drain it every time we use it
I like to irrigate my lawn I got a big
Garden got a couple cows out back and
you know I like ducks Etc does that
cover those things no but for a single
family residents we have standards it's
five gallons a minute for two hours any
24 hours a day we have these standards
and they are very applicable to solve
this problem when we get asked about
that as a well contractor we have to
fill out a report that says gallons per
minute and flow rate and if they're low
flow it's not uncommon for a customer to
say geez you did this well in 1998 you
show you had a gallon and three quarter
a minute I'd like to have a pump test
done
does that answer that's a long way of
any other questions members of the
committee
seeing none thank you very much thank
I have no other cards or any members of
the audience
[Music]
interested in speaking if not
I will close the hearing on House Bill
310.
and we will open up
okay
well
concerns there
I can't say your opposed sharing your
letter but
as
people remember to get a letter I mean I
have people calling me asking if you
ever tested your well and I'll have an
open the hearing and house bill 398.
relative to notice of pfas and other
groundwater contamination prior to the
sale of real property
and
chair recognizes representative Wendy
Thomas
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee I'm here to introduce Bill 398
which would require testing and
notification of pfas and other
groundwater contamination in water that
is connected with real estate property
this actually dovetails very nicely with
the bill that was heard this morning 205
which is for new wells that are that are
tested and representative wolf asked the
question what happens to existing Wells
so this bill would require that for any
sale of real estate property that the
water be tested if it's if it's um
private well the water be tested and the
potential buyer being notified prior to
the sale
um
the addition that I would also like to
include is that if there's if there's
contamination in public water that that
also be
notified to the buyer that doesn't
require testing that simply means going
to the uh the Water website because
they're required to test it on a regular
basis
now why all the big fuss about pfas I
live in Merrimack which is oh and by the
way
um I'm Wendy Thomas and I represent the
town of Merrimack sorry
um I live in the town of Merrimack and
we have an industrial polluter that has
been contaminating our town for decades
and I'll just share the personal story
that that I can put forward to show how
important this is
when we first heard about the
contamination in in our town the state
told us that only the houses that were
within a half mile radius of this
Corporation needed to worry about
contamination to their Wells
it didn't take long for the state to
realize that it was a bigger problem
than that and they expanded the area of
concern to a mile radius around this
Corporation
my house is three miles from this
Corporation but I have six children
they're adults now
um so I went and had our private well
tested the results came back so high
that we had to immediately shut our weld
down
when we installed a whole house
filtration system with a reverse osmosis
in the kitchen
um that's all that we that I would let
my kids drink from the reverse osmosis
for years about three years ago this
Corporation
um realized that
they potentially impacted our wells
they've never really taken
responsibility but um for the last three
years we've been supplied with bottled
water that's what we drink in our house
we cannot drink our well water it's too
poisonous to drink
um
the results even even with filtration
and everything the results of having
exposure to pfas and my family for so
long
um I've recently put down
um my fourth dog due to cancer and I I
don't have the big dogs I've got the
little dogs the little bedroom slipper
dogs these guys are the canaries in the
coal mine if you talk to people in my
town
um our cats and dogs are dying left and
right these they have little body weight
um personally
um I thought it was safe we put in a
whole house filtration system with
reverse osmosis been drinking water in
May of 2022 I was diagnosed with cancer
um at the advice of the environmental
working group I had my blood tested for
pfas for 40 pfas chemicals I have 12
chemicals in my body that are over the
toxic limit that's allowed for humans my
total pfoa
chemicals that are associated with
breast cancer I have more than 38 times
the toxic level that's allowed for
humans my total pfos which are related
to ovarian and fallopian cancer as well
as some others I have more than 99
percent of Americans do in in my body
when I went public with my story in my
town dozens of people reached out to me
with their cancer stories we have a ton
of cancer in our town not only do we
have cancer but we have autoimmune
disease
we have a autistic symptoms we have
thyroid issues we have high cholesterol
we have high blood sugar and those
aren't just inconveniences those are
killer diseases
um we have found out that women who
drink pfasts water during their
pregnancies at the levels that we see in
the town of Merrimack have a higher rate
of giving birth to babies with autistic
symptoms and learning disabilities
so this is not just something that's
nice to do this is this is protecting
the people of New Hampshire
and giving them a chance to
um protect themselves and their children
and their families
I will tell you that
um we are stuck in our house we cannot
sell our house right now I mentioned
earlier I have six children six adult
children only one is living at home we
have a very large house that we can't
sell who is going to buy a house with a
well that you cannot use the water
eventually we're supposed to at the cost
of the
that the cost of the corporation excuse
me we are supposed to be hooked up to
public water the dates on that um vary
from two years from now to seven years
from now
so we have no idea
um
if I knew our house had contaminated
water I would have never never purchased
it and I think that that's the fear of
some of the real estate agents but is
the price of selling a house and getting
a profit worth potentially
uh giving people lifelong illnesses and
cancer
now once I've said that
um I believe that this bill could be
rolled into the one you heard earlier
this morning which was 205 and I
understand that you're going to be
working on an amendment for that one I'm
not sure they need to be two separate
bills I think they can be rolled into
one real estate Bill where uh
notification of water needs to be done
before any transaction any real estate
transaction takes place
any questions by members of the
committee
on their originally
representative Darby the followed by
representative wolf
thank you Mr chairman um thank you for
sharing your story uh representative
Thomas
can you help me read this bill because I
see
I see notification which which basically
encourages buyers to test the water and
I see
um disclosure which says
we
I withdraw my question sorry I'm reading
let's see what what I'll come back to
you and uh in that scriptable
representative
representative wolf for a question and
I'll return to representative garby
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
this is a Statewide notification bill
that will be administered
or what is the penalty if somebody
just like this morning
um when we're talking about penalties
I'm not I'm not sure
I mean the penalty would be that I guess
you wouldn't buy the property I mean
there there is no no penalty I
would like to see one but I'm not quite
sure how you would go with that go ahead
and do that
um and the reason also this is Statewide
is because pfas is it flows it flows in
water it flows in air it's coming to a
town near you
if it's not already there
for a follow-up follow-up thank you
well
would it be
an appropriate remedy that the registry
of deeds
would not record a deed if that
acknowledgment is not included in the
deed
I hadn't thought of that but that would
be a simple way to do it I agree with
you
thank you
representative Darby for a question
thank you again Mr chairman
so I I guess I still need some
explanation on
398. because what I read in the existing
477 4A is that shall provide the
following notification and then the
language is added here you know starting
on line 26 on page one is a notification
about pfas including the buyers
encouraged to
um to test
and then the second section I see that
they need to disclose if they've
received notification from Des about
pfas but I don't see
when you your testimony started by
saying that it requires the water to be
tested prior to sale but I don't see
the the flow of this bill would need a
little bit of work
um I think we all know that OLS was a
little overwhelmed when they were doing
some of the bills and this was supposed
to match some of the other bills that
were out there but it doesn't I actually
think the wording of notification in 205
is stronger than than this bill so
that's one of the reasons I think I
think it could I think both of these
bills could be merged
if not though if you want to have it as
a separate bill I'd be happy to to um to
work on an amendment of it and push this
representative harbden
and Denver representative Vale thank you
representative for taking this question
I asked the question earlier to
representative Muse do you have a
problem if the effective date of the
bill is amended to uh January 1 2024.
representative Vale question
thank you Mr chair um thank you
representative Thomas for taking my
question I'm just wondering if you can
walk us through on page two from line
five to the um to nine where it says
disclosure required prior to the
um so I'm looking at this I'm I'm trying
to buy a house
so you're you're the buyer I'm the buyer
so um the seller would have to provide
the the testing and the notification the
seller would have to provide testing
I'm not sure that that Des
well actually
so so this bill says that Des would also
um have a have a statement but um that
would come after after the fact I mean
you can't hold up a house sale for Des
to do the notification
so this is primarily the testing
any other questions by members of the
committee
seeing none thank you very much
oh do you have a question thank you Mr
chair thank you representative Thomas
I don't see this is a notification bill
from what I'm reading it I don't see
where there's a requirement for testing
I'm not sure how one could notify
um
but you're right it doesn't exactly
representative wolves for a question
thank you as I read this bill
up until you get to section two it's all
about making the buyer aware of
radon arsenic lead and pfas was added to
an existing bill
so it's an acknowledgment that
that the buyer has been informed
that they have to that they are aware
that testing is available
period
the next one is if they require if they
have gotten a notice of a problem
then it has to be disclosed to the buyer
am I missing something
I think the intent of this bill is that
going forward in New Hampshire any real
estate transaction must require water
testing
and so Des has a has a water testing
profile
standard
thank you
I don't see in this bill anything
that says that you have to have your
um am I missing something
no I don't think you are which is why I
think this should be rolled in with 205
um because I think the wording on that
one is is stronger or again if we want
to make it um if this standalone so the
intent of this bill is to
as I said before any real estate
transaction in New Hampshire to have the
water tested and have the buyer be made
it doesn't require the seller to
remediate anything to put in a whole
house filtration system that's up to the
buyer to decide whether or not
they want to do that or if they want to
continue with purchasing the property
but we
as it was alluded to in 205 this morning
we all thought that our water in New
Hampshire was clean and safe
in the case of pfas you can't smell it
you can't taste it you can't see it
um it's it's come quite it's become an
issue and and certainly in Southern New
Hampshire but it's quite a shock to many
of us especially those of us with
private Wells that thought we were doing
the best things for our kids you know
you've got
water you know ice ice water from the
glaciers in our wells that kind of thing
um it just it's it's a shock to many of
us that we have been drinking poisoned
water for so long and we had no idea no
is that really cute
I have trouble seeing it all I see is a
thank you Mr chairman light behind you
thank you representative Thomas for
taking my question
specifically
the part that refers to an area within
500 feet of the subject real estate
could that require the seller
to research or have knowledge of
adjacent properties and how many
different adjacent properties would the
seller have to have knowledge and
disclose
the notification of groundwater
contaminations
so like numerous different properties
and how long would that hold up the
sale it that's the the Department of
Environmental Services is who keeps
track of the that their tested water
sites
um so to have
um so I guess they would have to check
that website to see where the
contaminated Wells are I do know that in
my particular neighborhood which is an
older neighborhood with lots of Wells
um several households have gotten
letters whenever they test a well and
there's property within 500 feet of that
they're automatically notified so I'm
not sure that that's something the real
estate agent would have to do as opposed
to the Department of Environmental
Services because that's one of the
things they take care of
anyone else
yeah
thank you Mr chair
um
so Wendy it sounds like I'm sorry
representative Thomas sounds it's okay
um it sounds like you would be open to
working with a subcommittee or working
with one of us on an amendment that
would
um I'm building off of Representative
Wolf's questions that would help the
bill
um
look like you want or do what you were
hoping it would do yes I would be very
open to it and I and I actually like
that suggestion of registry of deeds
um having some kind of authorization
over this
um again this was this is a bill that
was recommended by the 737 pfas
Commission
um
there are some
wording issues I I think
um
I'm gonna
I think it needs an amendment that's
what I'm going to say
but yes I would be very open to it and
and again I I think it dovetails with
205. I I think there there could be a
way that we could merge the two together
into one real estate bill but if you
want this to stand alone I would be more
than happy to work on them with with you
on an amendment on it
um yes um representative Thomas
um you had said from the 737 pfas
commission is that the house bill 737
statutory commission that we're talking
about yes it is thank you so much thank
you
is there anyone else for the question
seeing none
will not look any further
Brandon Kernan
thank you and Brandon Kernan
administrator of drinking water and
groundwater Bureau here to testify on
House Bill 398 and our understanding of
the bill it does two things one requires
that information be provided to
homeowners about the importance of
addressing pfas and testing it in about
its possible occurrence
and then two the other part of the bill
which we haven't really talked about
this today is if you are a current
homeowner and you're selling your
property and in the past you have
received a letter from the Department
saying that there's contamination and a
well within 500 feet of your property
that you disclose that you got that
letter when on a on a form to the
potential buyer of your home
as far as my testimony I mean obviously
the department thinks the education is
really important for pfest and perhaps I
can just reference the conversation
earlier today for House Bill 205 rather
than so we're rehashing that you know we
obviously think informing people is
really important
so I'll spend more time addressing that
just a disclosure requirement
you know we support the intent and we
think people should know when they're
buying a property if there are potential
concerns that they want to proactively
address as part of that transaction
we are concerned about this disclosure
requirement we think it could provide a
soft false sense of security and perhaps
there's a better ways to go about making
sure potential buyers are aware of
contamination concerns
I'll just outline why let me back up a
little bit there is a statute passed
back in the early 2000s that says when
there's a man-made contaminant over a
state standard an MCL or an ambient
groundwater quality standard that Dess
to notify all Property Owners within 500
feet that that that that result was
found in groundwater
and so that happens generally
systematically whenever we have an
exceedance of just a man-made
contaminant not naturally occurring
contaminants like arsenic or uranium
some of the challenges though is that
while we send these letters out we send
them out one time and so
properties change hands frequently in
some cases and it may be that even use
pfast example we started sampling in
2016 because we sent letters in 2016 to
people that might have had a result
nearby above a standard that property
changed hands the current property owner
who may now be selling the home wouldn't
have knowledge of that letter and so you
would not be disclosing it and someone
would have no reason to believe it might
be a concern separate of the education
component that that we talked about
earlier today
the other issue is that standards change
over time when we started sampling in
2016 we were notifying people if they
exceeded PFO mpfast over 70 parts per
trillion and our standard is now 12
parts per trillion and so people would
not have received that 500 foot letter
in that transition period from our old
standard to the new standard so again
you wouldn't be disclosing anything and
it might be a false sense of security
you know one other thing that happened
in Southern New Hampshire which is
really unique you know the many square
mile contamination area is we did
something better than the 500 foot
notification we just offered to sample a
bunch of people's Wells
um and saying that there's generally
contamination in the area and we weren't
playing around with 500 feet we were
picking large circles you know half
square miles out of our half mile
radiuses at a time and kept expanding
out and so while people got letters it's
not a 500 foot letter so to speak and so
that might cause confusion
another thing that's important is that
as I mentioned before we only do
notifications for man-made contaminants
it doesn't and so
just wouldn't address the possibility of
arsenic being in the groundwater above
standard which about 30 of homes how's
that challenge or uranium or manganese
our radon being elevated and so again
someone might feel falsely secure by the
fact that there's no letter being
disclosed to them
and then another one this is funny to me
but I'm in the business I'm kind of a
water nerd but people don't remember
they get notified there's been I get a
lot of calls routed to me for private
Wells I'm not the one administering it
but I get a lot of calls around it to me
and I know how to answer them and where
to find information so I do
but it's funny people ask why their well
was never sampled and we have a very
organized data structure that I can go
to any Town any road any address and
quickly see what we have for them
letters or data and we'll have an email
to that person in an email response for
the result and so people are asking why
they weren't sampled and they were it's
just life's chaotic lately and people
don't recall so people would not be
disclosing and you know forgetting that
they forgot you know that they did have
it done essentially so that's another
issue and then the mechanism for
enforcing this requirement is a question
you know first of all how would you do
it and so how could you really prove
someone knowingly didn't disclose a
letter because again we have clear
examples of people not remembering
we think what we talked about earlier
the education and Outreach is important
recommending testing when people are
buying homes is important and also
letting people know they should contact
DES if they want to find out about water
quality we might have for the address
they're buying or nearby addresses and
look at our data mapper we have a pfas
mapper if we're focusing on pfas where
you can look at any neighborhood and see
the general results you can't see
people's addresses we Grays out if you
go in too far because we're trying to
protect you know private private
information but ultimately it is all
private information if you called us and
said there's a lot of red dots in the
area you want to buy a home what what
are the results for this that and the
other address it's public information
public funds were used to buy it and
it's public information and we would get
that to you
going back to the registry of deeds
concept that's a good concept and
historically that's how we notified
people that their property was
contaminated and it would transfer to a
possible buyer
historically our waste sites were like a
gas station or a couple acre industrial
site and maybe a few homes nearby were
impacted and so once you delineated the
contamination we had what we call a
groundwater management Zone in our rules
in that zone all the land in that zone
had to have the associated
um the land area with the registry of
deeds you know the Lots recorded that
there's an active groundwater management
zone until it's cleaned up at which
point the reference to the ground
management Zone would be removed from
that lot with the registry of deeds and
that was really effective and it was
manageable because again it would these
relatively small sites and just a few
Lots we would have tens of thousands of
lots right now that we'd have to
register with the registry of deeds
based on the air emissions in Southern
New Hampshire and so while this hasn't
been put in place yet I know there's
discussions about coming up with some
sort of overlay identifying the area
Southern New Hampshire that potentially
could have been impacted by these
Regional emissions and all alternative
approach is being pursued because you
just can't go and put tens of thousands
of of recordings of the groundwater
management Zone on in the registry of
deeds for what we have going on in
Southern New Hampshire at this point
any questions but representative wrong
thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr
Kerner for taking my question
um in the letter that you distributed
from commissioner Scott on the second
page you note that homeowners that have
received a notification in the past may
not relate the notification they
received to the proposed new disclosure
requirement
so this brings up two questions of mine
one is that disclosure or that that
um disclosure notification is that
addressed specifically to that homeowner
does it or does it just you know to whom
it may concern no it's specifically
addressed to that homeowner we um
essentially have a Statewide tax map in
GIS that has mailing addresses for all
the current property owners and so we
can plop a circle right on it and pull
the names and mailing addresses and the
letters go right out so I'm letting them
know within 500 feet you have this
result so it's customized letter form
language for the most part but it's
targeting by name and address
who's within 500 feet okay follow-up so
what I'm hearing you say and from this
letter is that homeowners may get that
personalized first class letter but just
kind of disregard it they don't really
consider it seriously so that if they're
selling their home and they see that
they have to disclose if they've
received a letter it might Escape their
mind
but I'm having a hard time reconciling
reconciling that with the expectation
that a prospective buyer would know
enough to go to Des on their own and
look up the map and everything to me the
homeowner would retain the in would
retain that notification of like oh wow
I got this letter
much more than a prospective buyer would
say oh I need to go to
des.nh.gov and look up their their
mapping so I I'm just having a hard time
if you can help me reconcile that those
two approaches a buyer and then a seller
would have on addressing the need for
becoming informed about potential pfas
that might be in their well
so I definitely think a buyer
could be prompted to do that work and
would do the work if they were given
information on how to do that work up
front to look to see what information is
in that area it wouldn't cross their
mind if that someone didn't suggest it
to them so perhaps
through the work of 205 or this bill you
know something proactive saying we
encourage you to look at records of the
Department of Environmental Service to
see what's available for information in
the area and so that would prompt them
as far as the seller it's kind of lost
on me how people forget these things but
again I think about water all the time
but I get these calls all the time where
people ask why their Wells weren't
tested and we did test it and we have
responses for them Thanking us they call
they email us asking somebody I don't
know if it was a company or you guys
tested or well four years ago and I've
never got the result and I'm trying to
figure it out and we have the result we
have our correspondence to them
I'm not saying it's gonna happen all the
time but I'm saying it's a real issue
yeah if yours goes on it's funny that
some people lose track of what happened
in the past relative to this issue okay
representative wolf for a question I can
chairman thank you for taking my
question does Des keep a database of all
of these letters that they have sent out
I assume but I'm not confused assume do
they send them out certified and do they
keep a database
no we did not send them out certified as
far as the database we have something
akin to the database it's very organized
file directory we have a directory for
every town and like on it on your on a
network drive and then for every town we
have a road every road is down and then
you have every subdirectory with the
street number and So within two minutes
if you say 10 Brown Hill Road and bow I
can tell you if we have something or Not
by just going to that directory like
that
thank you so it would be relatively easy
for either a buyer or a seller
to
contact DES and find out whether
um the notice has been sent out as in
section two
yes
so okay what would be difficult is
if it became a full-time job for someone
to answer those inquiry inquiries that
that could be done but our resources
would be needed because we don't have a
person available to answer real estate
calls all day long right now
now uh
good afternoon Mr chair members of the
committee thank you for taking my
testimony my name is Chris Norwood I am
a commercial real estate broker uh owner
of a real estate firm in New Hampshire
with offices in Bedford and Portsmouth
I'm also the 2022 chair 23 chair of the
New Hampshire Association of Realtors
as written were opposed to the bill
however we certainly it sounds like
there is momentum to create some sort of
working group or study group on this and
we're happy to participate in that I
hope to clear up a couple questions that
have been raised earlier so first we see
two points in this bill on the first
page lines 26 through uh line two of the
following page is adding an additional
notification so representative I believe
the question came up earlier the
distinction between notification and
disclosure and I'll try and be precise
with my language today when I go to
inform a seller or a buyer about the
difference in our state statute between
notification and disclosure notification
I take to mean these things radon
arsenic lead and could potentially be
pfas are things that exist in the state
of New Hampshire the subject property
may or may not have those contaminants
but they exist somewhere in the state of
New Hampshire so relative to the
notification piece in this bill the Bold
piece a language similar to this we
think could be appropriate I think we
have some concerns when we introduce on
line 26 words like common
because there are parts of the state
where it is not common
again okay inserting General language of
notification I think the word smithing
of exactly what goes into that should
should be looked into
the second section of this bill where we
view it on the second page line three
through line 10.
is a disclosure
when I talk to buyers and sellers I use
the word disclosure to say a known
defect as do you Mr Mrs seller know
about this defect in your property and
to give you a flavor of some of the
disclosures that are required you have
is your property an asbestos dump RSA
141 is your property a condo RSA 356
what type of water do you have RSA 477
what type of sewer do you have RSA 477
and those disclosures contain an
obligation for the the seller to
participate in that disclosure they have
to say do I know this yes no unknown
when was the last time I had my sewer
tested yes no unknown date of the sewer
test so the reason I raise that in this
second section is where we have some
struggle with I know that there's been
some testimony relative to would a
seller remember that they got the letter
in the mail did they even open it or did
they end up in the waste basket and we
concur with those
but the other piece as a practitioner
this disclosure is the only disclosure
that I can think of where you are
disclosing a deficiency on an adjoining
parcel or a parcel further down the
street so you're not disclosing
something that is uh wrong or deficient
in your subject property but rather
again a well that was tested 500 feet
away and again that can just go through
you know asbestos dump is your property
an asbestos dump is your property a
condo what is the water or sewer at your
property so
um that's the other piece that we're
struggling and we're having an issue
with again as a whole I think that the
the notification piece we're comfortable
with some sort of language to add I
think that that is appropriate and I
believe uh representative harb you
mentioned making it effective uh January
1 that's good for us to train our
practitioners get the two-year
accreditation for all of our
our instructors and so forth and the
forms to be updated that's would be very
appreciated as well and I'll accept any
questions thank you Mr chair
any questions by any members of the
committee
representative Lamontagne thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question
most of the discussion has been about
testing and notification
um
representing the Realtors do you think
it should be common practice
to put in real estate contracts that if
the water is found to be contaminated
that would be a common or should we put
in contingency clauses
that would allow someone to back out
of the purchase
if the water is found to be contaminated
thank you representative for the
question
I think that the
so most of my business is on the
commercial front and in our world I
actually sold property that have had
pfas contamination whereby it was
discovered but the buyer elected to go
ahead without any remediation because we
were already on Municipal Water so the
determination was it's a known
contaminant it's in the ground water
you're not going to drink from the
faucet excuse me you're not going to
drink from the groundwater because you
have it from the municipality
we elected not to get out of the deal we
elected to move ahead
most contracts have some sort of due
diligence Clause whereby the buyer and
seller agree that the buyer can conduct
their diligence we all know in the last
18 months uh the amount of diligence
being done is very thin because the
market is so hot but as we have more
inventory
the buyers do elect to have a little bit
more power and they are performing those
diligence items in the same way that
they would perform
other property inspections like a lead
paint test if they so choose
anyone else
what a question
Senator Darby
thank you Mr chair um thank you for
taking my question all right so talking
about disclosures
um we were passed out a disclosure in an
earlier bill
um which I happen to look at and and
have a copy online and the disclosure
has a statement now about has your water
been tested and what were the results
and were there any remediations
would it be reasonable
um to uh to add specific questions into
that disclosure was attested for you
know pfas was it tested for Radon things
like that
thank you representative for having the
question
um I I think that that would be fair
um I'm trying to think about our
specific disclosures and also the
notification these notifications also go
within our purchase and sales agreement
that the standard forms happy to share
those with the committee
um relative to your specific question
what makes me more comfortable with that
as opposed to the language in the bill
is again it goes back to
um
knowledge of something that took place
on a property that's not your own and
that to me is where I'm wrestling with
it's that you received a letter in the
mail on a property that was down the
road you may have not opened the letter
and and again I'm disclosing something
that's something that's outside of my
the four pillars of my meats and Bounds
does that answer the question
representative
um yes and and it'd be great if you
could forward those notifications you
that are you including the purchase and
sales
seeing
seeing no one
I have no more further pink cards is
there
as I got them all
I will close the uh hearing on
House Bill 398 and go right into
2 30. house bill
microphone is yours thank you Mr
chairman committee uh this is uh
Hospital 592 relative to uh buffers
around wetlands
uh as the paperwork states that bill
exempts temporary impacts and small
impervious Services impact
projects from local overlay districts
permits for construction excavation or
filling near wetlands basically allows a
property owner to use additional land
within the 50-foot of a wetland
and if you would allow me I disability
submitted on behalf of the honorable Mr
Campbell and he is present this
afternoon and can make a better
presentation that I can if you
will allow me
uh I will recognize then if you're
finished I will recognize
I Am The Honorable Mr Campbell I had the
opportunity to serve on resources
Recreation and development and I hate to
say it it was over 20 years ago now
um I was a much uh younger man then and
uh it's interesting to see that you're
stealing dealing with uh speed limits on
the Lakes
disclosures on water quality
and wetlands issues so my hope is to
sort of bring the perspective of of why
did I file this bill and part of it was
partly because one of the bills I passed
when I was a representative on resources
Recreation and development was a
definition of a wetland
so prior to 2000 every municipality had
their own definition of a wetland and it
varied from town to town some would use
hydric a soils some would use hydric
bees and those areas that were
considered a wetland vary greatly from
town to town so we what we did in a
bipartisan way and I say it was
bipartisan because there was people on
both sides of the aisle that were for it
and there was people on both sides of
the aisle that were against it so
imagine today 20 years later if you
didn't have a consistent definition of a
wetland
I think we can all agree now that that
was a good decision 20 years ago and I
can say that that legislation I passed
20 years ago is still the law of the
land so I think we did something right
and this bill is very similar except
that it deals with Uplands and what the
problem I'm seeing is because
municipalities can't Define their
Wetlands differently they Define the
area around their Wetlands differently
now in the legislation that we passed we
enabled municipalities to define unique
features we enabled them to do
additional setbacks from Prime wetlands
the bill that I'm attempting to pass now
doesn't affect Lakes doesn't affect
surling protection make sure you read
the Des comments it changes no other
state permits it doesn't affect any of
the Shoreland protection stuff any of
the Great Lake stuff any of the Prime
Wetland stuff what we're really talking
about here is just your run-of-the-mill
basic you know
Wetland that's uh meets the criteria but
isn't considered a prime Wetland isn't a
bog is in a kettle hole doesn't change
any of the New Hampshire Heritage
requirements for endangered species none
of that would be affected essentially
the point of view that I'm coming from
is that you can't in a lot of these
towns cut trees down in these buffers
and that's a problem for me because I'm
a solar power developer now so I build
solar trackers and obviously you need
access to the sunlight so oddly a lot of
towns have adopted ordinances to protect
the wetlands in the name of protecting
the wetlands and the water quality and
the in the critters they've adopted a
lot of buffer setbacks and these buffer
setbacks in a lot of ways have become
green belts or they've even become in
some towns conservation easements across
the entire State across everyone's
property rights so how do you strike the
balance between individual property
rights and and the need for protecting
wetlands and I think the way you you
strike that balance is by respecting
that you have to meet a minimum
threshold of impact a minimum threshold
of impact before you have additional
conditional overlay districts or
conditional use permits so literally I
had to get a conditional use permit in
one town be because an area where I was
mowing which was in within 50 feet of a
wetland you know caught in the grass
it's a lawn area happened to be within
50 feet of a wetland we were going to
put a solar base in the Solar base was
literally less than 10 square feet of
concrete
six thousand dollars and months and
months later in permitting to get a
conditional use permit I felt was just a
little bit overburdism for what we were
doing given the common sense of there
was no measurable drainage impact there
was no change in the lawn other than the
very limited temporary eight by eight
disturbance that we were doing so it was
just a little bit far-reaching in
another town we were able to get a
permit to do an intent to cut and we
were able to file the appropriate
permits to cut all the wetlands but then
there was a 25 foot buffer around the
whole area of trees that would block our
access to the Sun so we had to go
through again a lengthy conditional use
permit process and it was a process
where they said you could have
absolutely no building within 25 feet of
a wetland
so this is in my opinion in a you know
something that's not enabled under the
land use statutes that if you're trying
to protect the wetlands from doing
something that you're allowed to do in
the wetlands I have letters here from
Dave Price at DES essentially you can
cut in wetlands and some of you might be
shocked by that I can tell you I go to a
lot of conservation commissions and a
lot of planning boards and I explain to
them that I don't need a state permit to
cut the trees in the wetlands I only
need their conditional use permit to cut
the trees in the Uplands and they get
very angry with me and they think I'm
lying I send them an email I tell the
planner call Dave Price you know I
follow all the state rules I sat on this
committee I sat on oversight committees
with Des I think I'm a relatively
informed guy although I'll admit I still
have a lot to learn so I hope that you
will understand that I'm not trying to
supersede any local control every local
ordinance that's currently written can
be written it probably doesn't need to
be changed the only thing that would
happen is you'd have to have three
thousand square feet of impervious
impact
and so think of that as like a
residential house within 50 feet of the
wetlands then you would follow all of
those additional permitting stuff all of
the additional overlay districts you're
not going to be exempt from local zoning
at all you'd still have to follow local
zoning you just wouldn't have to say go
to the Conservation Commission and say
may I do one thousand square feet of
impact 50 feet away from a wetlands
so it'd be a very limited threshold and
I would submit to you that this is a
very good idea because Des Wetlands
permits use those same thresholds
essentially your your lowest impact Des
Wetlands permit is three thousand square
feet to do work in a Wetlands so I
didn't pick 3 000 square feet in a
vacuum I said well if I'm going to do
work in an Upland let's pick 3 000
square feet as the threshold to trigger
additional permitting so all that
additional local permitting can stay in
place it just can't be triggered unless
a homeowner is doing something that
exceeds three thousand square feet I
watched a neighbor of mine whose uncle
came over and popped a stump for him
because he had cut a tree down and then
they found out it was 44 feet away from
the Wetland then they had to do an after
the fact conditional use permit they had
to survey it they had to do all this
figure out a remediation plan to Simply
remove one stump
and I would just submit to you that that
had no impact on the wetlands was an
unreasonable thing to do and I don't
even think the town meant to be that
judicious about it it was just
nonetheless that's the way their local
permit read so they had to do it when
they looked at it so what I'm asking is
that there'd be a threshold before these
additional conditional use permits come
in and I'll speak a little bit to the
planning board process when you go to
the planning board and you complete a
complete application you meet the
threshold that the planning board can
make a decision so when we meet that
threshold the planning board then says
oh we can accept the application as
complete and by Statute they have 65
days to give you an answer that whole
process is now out the window because a
lot a lot of these planning boards are
doing and say well sorry you need a
conditional use permit we need you to go
to a third party volunteer board that's
not a legislative body that doesn't have
the power to vote doesn't have the power
to notice people of a public hearing
it's a voluntary board and you can spend
three or four months in that voluntary
board explaining that it's okay to cut
trees down in a wetland and they don't
want to let you cut it down in the
Uplands and of course you need to cut
trees down for the solar the solar will
more than generate the power to do that
so this is a private property Rights
bill this is a bill that would like when
we defined Wetlands bring a semblance at
least a minimum threshold of what all
the municipalities could do when it
comes to these Wetland setbacks remember
there is no Wetland setback at the state
level
outside of Shoreland protection outside
of great ponds on a wetland there is no
State requirement for a setback
and you could get a Wetlands permit so
on one project we couldn't build in the
buffer so we had to kick three tractors
into the wetlands and get a Wetlands
permit because that was allowed and you
could do that so obviously I would have
rather built them 10 12 feet into the
Upland and not into the wetlands but
given that the local
body had no administrative remedy maybe
a variance but there was no unique
condition so they didn't really have to
give you a variance so these things are
actually hurting wetlands and my number
one not my number one but the thesis
that a lot of Engineers say to me is
when they're doing a Wetlands permit
they try really hard to be under 3 000
square feet
so if you're going to build anywhere
near a wetlands and there's this magic
number stay 50 feet away and you don't
get any local permitting
how many people are going to stay 50
feet away I would submit everyone
because no one wants additional
permitting
and I would submit if you had to do work
within 50 feet of a Wetlands you would
try real hard not to impact more than 3
000 square feet
so I think this will do more to protect
the wetlands in the state of New
Hampshire it'll protect property rights
by at least saying here's a level that
you know you can go and get a permit and
I think that makes it a bipartisan
hopefully bipartisan way and I don't
mean necessarily bipartisan but a way to
look at how do we balance property
rights and conservation
I've done a lot of conservation over the
years I've given a lot of land of
Confrontation I've done a lot of
conservation developments I believe in
conservation but I don't think local
towns should adopt ordinances that
impose a green belt or a conservation
easement on your land near Wetlands I
think that is a taking of the land and I
think that if you're going to have these
additional regulations you need to have
that minimum threshold I know that
there's you know obviously opposition
every bill and I I'm sure all the people
with orange name tags are going to come
up and tell you oh the municipal
Association oppose the bill and I don't
even know if they do I'm just saying
that that you would get
um concerned about anybody who's going
to supersede local rights for local
control I'm a live for your guy kind of
guy from a small town in Rochester I
believe in local control but local
control should not mean that you have by
ordinance a green belt on your land and
local control should not mean thousands
and dollars and months and months of
additional permitting for minor impacts
in an Upland not in a wetland in an
Upland and I can go to Des and I can get
a Wetlands permit but I can't go to my
local planning board or Conservation
Commission and get a Uplands permit so
that's a problem and I think that it
makes sense to strike a compromise at
the straight level and bring uniformity
across all planning boards and all
zoning that just says there's a minimum
threshold and I'll leave with this I'm
open to however you want to skin that
cat I picked 3 000 because it was
consistent with what Wetlands permits do
three thousand ten thousand twenty
thousand if you say in the Upland you
want it to be 2 000 or a thousand I'm
not stuck on that number I just think
there has to be a minimum number and I
think three thousand is a reasonable
number because if it's less than three
thousand you don't have drainage issues
you don't have you know fast runoff you
don't have the things that might impact
a Wetlands because it's such a small
area so that's the other reason why I
picked the 3000 and I picked the 50-foot
setback because that seems to be a
popular setback with towns most of them
do 50 feet but I will tell you that some
towns have 150 foot overlay districts
from a regular Wetland and literally
have told me I can't build within 150
feet so if you own a two acre lot in a
commercial Zone which I do and then I'm
told I can't build my additional storage
units or my additional solar that I got
a variance to build and a non-conforming
use because of an overlay District that
takes away literally half of my lot I
would submit to you that that's an
economic taking in an economic hardship
so if you know in that site plan that I
have we don't have any impervious
surface within 50 feet and I've been
denied by the planning board and the in
the in the local Conservation Commission
the ability to do that project there's
no impact other than needing to cut
trees down so the solar panels can look
out across the sky there's no
improvement in service surface there's
no temporary disturbances other than
cutting the vegetation so that's a big
motive invasion of why I'm here today is
I'd like to be able to develop that
property and if you pass a state law
that says you have to have a minimum
impact or a state law that says if you
have no permanent impacts and I Define
that in the bill what a permanent impact
is can read that if I don't have any of
that then I should have a right to build
up my property because I'm 50 feet away
from a wetland and oddly the same thing
applies I could apply for a Wetlands
permit to build a little finger of
wetlands and it wouldn't be a thing they
could do about it because there's no
conditional use permit so obviously I
don't want to move I could actually move
one of The Trackers into the Wetland and
then make them happy and have a Tracker
not in their buffer but that makes no
sense to me I'm hopeful that this
committee will take the time please meet
with me in subcommittee if you want I
see you want to exec this on the 8th I'm
happy to meet with you between now and
the 8th I'm happy to look at amendments
I'm happy to address any of the concerns
that other stakeholders rightfully might
bring up but I want to be clear doesn't
change any other state permits
doesn't prevent local zoning from being
in place it just sets a minimum
threshold to get it done thank you for
any questions by members of the
committee
representative wrong
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question you mentioned that
there are some activities that you can
do within a Wetlands that you can't do
in the buffer
I think you cite an example of cutting
trees were there other activities Mr
Campbell yeah there's there's a lot of
activities pretty much every
I can do impervious surface in a wetland
and I can do trackers in a wetland I
mean you have to get a Wetlands permit
from Des which is a process and they do
have the ability to say no but in the
case of one of my projects I have seven
acres of land about three acres of it is
Upland and then about four acres of it
is wetland so I want to do about what
amounts to less than 200 feet of impact
in the Wetland in order to spread my
trackers out and get the Sun so I would
submit that that's a very reasonable
thing to do so I can put the concrete
base in the underground conduit in the
Wetland but I can't put the concrete
Upland near the Wetland because of local
zoning in at least three towns that I'm
aware of and it sounds like there might
be more towns that I think inadvertently
have just gone a little too far and
because you can cut trees down without a
permit the basic justification is oh
we're protecting the wetlands you
shouldn't cut trees down
but you can cut trees down in the
Wetland so how is that an item that
you're you know enabled to do and I I
hate to bring up lawsuits but I only had
one lawsuit in my Development Career and
it was related to not being able to cut
down trees within 15 feet of a property
line and the town was saying well we
want privacy and we want these trees we
went to court with Superior Court they
said no that's not a unique feature it
was right after we passed the wetlands
ordinance and they had to find trees
this unique feature and the judge said
no trees aren't a unique feature and we
live in a state where a lot of people do
timber cutting and logging and it's a
it's an industry and to tell people that
they can't cut logs down on these wood
Lots they would be able to cut the logs
in the wetlands on a woodlot but not the
logs in a buffer and and so cutting is
probably the main thing that you can't
do in most of these ordinances but any
other construction activity that you can
think of almost without exception with a
Wetlands permit you can you can do it in
the wetlands
to follow or follow-up okay thank you so
um you're raising issues with towns
having different
requirements for these buffer zones have
you had any
um success or have you tried to
influence those towns to change those
requirements actually I've had a lot of
success
um
Dover is in the process of updating
their solar ordinance I brought a solar
ordinance that Rochester is the city of
Rochester is bringing online it's been
about a one year process
and they had a they had their first
public reading uh two days ago so
um I would submit to you that it's
possible to influence those things at a
local level and I would also submit to
you that I think most of those talents
have been reasonable and sympathetic in
Rochester although I blatantly broke
their their no cut buffer
um because I did it quite honestly as
part of a Timber Harvest and I had no
idea given that I had permits to cut in
the wetlands that I couldn't just cut
the law we were doing a change of use
the bazel law didn't apply and we cut it
and then a year later I go to the
planning board and they're like what do
you mean you cut all the trees I cut
them a year ago like oh you can't do
that I'm like are you serious so they
were very understanding because they
knew I wasn't trying to skirt their
rules I just was like jumping into the
cold lake when someone told me that I
didn't have the right to cut trees and
harvest Timber on my land and I'm not
saying I'm a logger but over the years
I've I've made a little bit of money
buying wood lots and cutting the wood
lot and selling the wood and then
developing it later or selling it it
it's it's a way a lot of people in New
Hampshire make a living and I would
submit to you that if you have these
Green Belt buffers even though they have
been accommodating for the most part
that you should have a minimum threshold
as Guidance just like we have a minimum
threshold of the three criteria for a
wetland it's the same the same
philosophy so I hope that you guys will
support that philosophy
any other any other questions members of
the board
of Representative LaMontagne uh thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question
I'm having a little hard time following
what you're saying
um
you're saying that you can do just about
anything in the wetlands but you still
have to get a permit to do it it's not
that you don't go through a process in
order to do those activities in the
Wetland correct
um
sort of if I was putting Concrete in a
wetland in a permanent and serious
surface you would need at least a
minimum impact permit but if I was just
cutting trees in a wetland I would not
need a permit in most Wetlands you can
cut I brought a copy of the
administrative rules because I know some
people find that hard to believe and I'm
happy to share that with the committee
if you need me to but I would hope that
you would trust me when I tell you that
yes you can cut trees in a wetland
without a permit you just have to use
best management practices which means
dry soil conditions Frozen soil
conditions when you cut in a wetland but
you are absolutely allowed under New
Hampshire state law to cut trees in a
wetland
so you would not need a permit to answer
your question you would not need a
permit to cut trees in a wetland but you
would need a conditional use permit to
cut trees in an Upland and some
communities have chosen not to issue
those conditional use permits literally
on the grounds that we might hurt the
wetlands that we can cut so that's and
that's the Dilemma that I think we need
to set a minimum standard and in the
bill I do Define what a disturbance is
and I Define what a temporary
disturbance is so in one town we looked
at a disturbance and it said basically
you know cut vegetation turn soil
um have a permanent impact so like
Wetlands I thought that meant Wetlands
vegetation seasonal high water table and
soil type
thus is a wetland two is not
two of these is not
you need all three to be defined as a
Wetlands by a wetland scientists
I thought in order to be considered a
disturbance in their buffer you needed
to do all three and and it wasn't clear
the ordinance wasn't clear the ordinance
allowed for Timber harvesting to happen
in their buffer without a auto permit
um but essentially I got an
administrative decision that said no if
you caught you need a conditional use
permit and that's where I think there's
a major problem with the state not just
setting down a basic guideline that I
hope you can see as reasonable just like
we came together 20 years ago and said
that having a definition from a wetland
is a reasonable thing so I think a
hopefully a a definition for a minimum
impact before you trigger this
additional local land use perming that
you can still do you just would need to
be impacting at least three thousand
square feet before you got that
additional permit just like in a
Wetlands before you have to apply for a
permit you have to be doing more than
just cutting trees
okay
that didn't answer your question
yes okay thanks
then turn it off
is there anyone else wishes to ask a
is
okay I presume that's not a question
she was just asking for me oh okay
nobody asked me that's an important
question thank you very much thank you
all right uh
I'll call uh
Darlene Horst
Representatives thank you for allowing
us an opportunity to speak today my name
is Darlene Forrest I am currently the
administrator of the wetlands Bureau at
the New Hampshire Department of
Environmental Services
we did email a letter of testimony to
the chair of the committee hopefully it
was distributed already I will note
there is a typo in that email and it
cites Roman numeral
title Roman numeral
X1 XIV it should be lxiv I do have
corrected copies if anyone feels like
that is a matter of great importance
that they want to
have a corrected copy before I leave
today
that said
um what we would like to to state today
is having listened to the gentleman's
testimony just now
the language that we see in this bill
might not do exactly what its intention
is
what we see in this bill is language
that would
not allow a town to regulate any project
that has
any amount of impact provided there's
less than three thousand square feet of
new impervious that happens within 50
feet of a wetland
frankly that is a matter of local
control
that has nothing to do with the impart
environment Department of Environmental
Services
we are not going to speak to matters of
local control that is that is a very
passionate issue in the state of New
Hampshire that many people would like to
discuss we have enough to do
what we would like to ask is since this
does not affect State permitting and it
does not affect the way the state
approaches Wetlands it is a matter of
local control it would seem far more
transparent if it was located in title
LX 1V whatever Roman numeral that
equates to which is Planning and Zoning
where local municipalities will expect
to find it
where it can be properly you know
transparent
um
and discussed
so that is our that's that's the the sum
total of what we would like to say we do
truly believe that
for clarity
this is not a Wetlands issue and does
not belong in Wetland statute or at
is there any questions for uh
representative harp requested
thank you thank you for taking this
question you mentioned that in this
proposed that talks about the 3000 feet
of permanent impervious impact
would it make a difference to you if it
unto us and it's all about whether or
not a town has a right to require a
permit or put in an overlay
so our position would again be this is a
matter of local control and should be in
Planning and Zoning statutes thank you
I I have a question in uh the buffer
zones are
buffer zones part of the uh part of the
wetlands ordinances a Wetlands laws of
these uh
under your jurisdiction
so there are two buffers that are
allowed under specifically the Wetland
statute one is for a period of time
towns who designated Prime Wetlands had
the ability to adopt with that a 100
foot right Prime Wetland buffer there's
also the 100 foot tidal buffer zone
those are the only two state level
buffers
I will note this the reason that we do
not require
a permit to cut trees in Wetlands is
because the legislature has not given us
the authority to require a permit to cut
trees and wetlands we have we require
permits for construction excavation
dredge
and fill sorry excavation removal and
fill none of those describe the cutting
of trees so we leave that to the
Department of Natural Resources we just
regulate fill for roads
um we're not asking for that right now
but the explanation for why that there's
a discrepancy there is we don't have
that Authority
uh I will also note that I know of
nothing within wetland's statute which
would prohibit the town from adopting
such Authority
okay
any other questions from members of the
Margaret burns from New Hampshire
good afternoon I'm Margaret burns the
executive director excuse me of the
municipal Association and we are here
this afternoon in opposition to house
bill 592. I guess I'd like to start by
echoing the prior testimony that the
matter involved with this bill is a
matter of local control and that is the
main reason for our opposition to the
bill I would also like to agree with
prior testimony that should a bill like
this pass it certainly does not belong
in RSA chapter 482 the authority of
municipalities to regulate zoning is
found in RSA chapter 674 and 674 section
17 and 674 section 21 specifically give
municipalities the authority to identify
and create regulations that preserve
natural resources and that is part of
most zoning ordinances as I said the
main reason for our opposition is that
this would override local control
I believe I heard some testimony earlier
that I thought I understood to be that
this would not require the rewriting or
changing of local zoning ordinances but
there are many municipalities that have
enacted local Wetlands buffer ordinances
that would be impacted by House Bill 592
if it were to pass and would therefore
override their ability at the local
level to make these decisions
many municipalities as I understand it
do require additional permits for
impervious impact projects of less than
100 square feet I understand that the
rationale for these requirements is
concern over cumulative impacts of many
different projects and what that can
mean for the area and for the natural
resources our municipalities have worked
hard to look at and identify natural
resources and to pass local ordinances
to address these issues to preserve
water quality other natural resources
wildlife and all the things that go
along with Wetlands organ offenses and
wetlands buffer ordinances so we would
respectfully ask the committee to see
this as a local issue as an issue
already addressed in existing law giving
cities and towns the authority to
regulate through zoning and to recommend
this bill as inexpedient to legislate I
am happy to take any questions that the
committee has but I would like to note
that there are people sitting behind me
far more knowledgeable with respect to
Wetlands ordinances and wetlands buffers
who are probably better positioned to
answer your specific questions if you
have them and I have submitted written
testimony on behalf of the municipal
Association via email earlier today
thank you
any questions by members of the
committee
see none
Barbara Richter from the New Hampshire
thank you very much for the ability to
provide testimony on House Bill 592 my
name is Barbara Richter I'm the
executive director at the New Hampshire
Association of conservation commissions
nhacc is a non-profit organization that
serves 217 conservation commissions here
in the state
many of our members as well as our board
are opposed to house bill 592.
we have concerns that this bill is
unclear it should not be part of RSA 482
a and it also limits Municipal rights
another concern we have is that the
lodge the language does not address the
restoration or best management practices
of those temporary impacts
just because a project is small does not
mean that it doesn't cause erosion
siltation or compacted soils
often temporary can mean two or more
years so there really can be some
significant impacts when you're looking
at some of these smaller projects so
please vote an expedient to legislate on
House Bill 592.
towns should be able to use a
science-based approach in their decision
making and this bill would limit that
power
loss of wetlands is an increasing threat
to our health and our environment
New Hampshire loses approximately 90
Acres of wetlands every year and with
that loss is a significant loss in our
um
Wetlands provide groundwater recharge
for our drinking water
flood water storage
nutrient and toxic filtration sediment
trapping wildlife habitat Shoreland
stabilization and storm water management
foreign
ly and towns really understand this and
they're trying very hard to protect
these significant resources currently
about 70 percent of New Hampshire towns
have local Wetland regulations and the
ones that I have read do allow for
forestry and agriculture so they they do
permit a lot of the uses that we're
concerned about today
restricting local regulations will will
come at a cost to New Hampshire
municipalities
right now House Bill 276 is asking for
25 million dollars to help address
cyanobacteria
and if we can't protect our Wetlands
we'll just continue to see these
increases in Need for funding to support
our health and well-being so please vote
itl on House Bill 592. I'd be happy to
answer any questions that you may have
any questions by members of the
committee
thank you for taking my question
um thank you
as I I'm a former conservation
commissioner as I see right now
seven towns have buffers of less than 50
feet
at least 27 so far that I see have child
have buffers of zones of over 50 feet is
my question is if my town only has a
buffer of 25 feet and this is put in
place just now my town have to have a
buffer of 50 feet
I mean that's a very good question I'm
probably not able to answer that just by
reading this um the language in this
bill so it's hard to clarify how that's
going to impact those local regulations
so that's why we have this concern thank
you
any other questions from members of the
committee
may I add one more
piece to to address
um I do understand that solar
regulations could be an issue here
um and I do don't know that a lot of
towns are working hard to update their
solar regulations or even you know
create them many towns don't have a
specific
zoning to
deal with solar power and I can
understand how that could be a problem
but I don't think it's the wetlands that
were
at issue here because
um
there there's you know there's
definitely a need for updated
regulations in a lot of communities and
again solar is one that they're trying
hard to kind of keep up to date with so
any any other questions the members of
the committee
seeing seeing none
thank you very much
good afternoon chair uh rentugo and
members of the committee I'm here
representing myself I have spent many
years on my Town's planning board and
Conservation Commission which I'm both
currently on and I am also a
professional Wetland scientist so I'd
like to review
um I did submit uh written
testimony as well although it didn't go
through the first time but I'd like to
um go through that and then I'd make
some other points so I'm writing to
express my opposition to House Bill 592
which seeks to significantly reduce the
ability of municipalities to protect
local Wetland resources this bill
undermines the protection of State
Wetland and surface water resources upon
which all of us depend on to live and
enjoy what New Hampshire has to offer
direct impacts to New Hampshire's
wetlands and surface waters have been
regulated under state law since 1967. in
recognition of the significant role
Wetlands play in protecting water
quality and quantity mitigation
mitigating flood waters and providing
wildlife habitat among other functions
however Wetlands cannot perform these
functions effectively without buffers
the Upland areas adjacent to Wetlands
are crucial to many of the functions and
values of wetlands and surface waters
while the state's Wetland RSA 42a
regulates activities and buffers to some
resources as Ms Forrest mentioned RSA
674 colon 21 Roman numeral 1j authorizes
municipalities to enact environmental
characteristic zoning to better protect
local wetlands and other resources
I'll address a couple of points about
the importance of buffers and the Not So
in insignificant issues with temporary
impacts in my letter there is a diagram
from a Connecticut River joint
commission's publication that
illustrates the general distances at
which buffers protect certain functions
of wetlands and streams vegetated
buffers intercept sediment nutrients
pesticides and other materials in
surface runoff
sediments carry phosphorus a fertilizer
to our wetlands and surface waters when
there are inadequate buffers
for nutrient removal and sediment
control functions to protect water
quality according to the diagram and a
significant body of research the buffers
needed range from 75 to 125 feet in
width
New Hampshire has had increasing
cyanobacteria blooms in 2021 Des issued
32 Health advisories and over 40 alerts
which was at that time a record-breaking
year for observed wombs such blooms are
toxic to people and animals and can
create taste and odor issues in drinking
water
Research indicates that cyanobacteria
abundance increases as light nutrients
increase if the ability to protect
Wetland buffers that assist in water
quality protection our Wetlands lakes
and streams and the real estate near
them will be negatively affected
House Bill 592's reference the temporary
impacts is based on a presumption that
temporary impacts are just that however
this is not accurate temporary impacts
can create long-term disturbances which
provide an open invitation for invasive
plants to move in even if the area has
been revegetated invasive plants
negatively affect wildlife and can
impair the use of our wetlands and other
resources water resources so I hope the
committee will consider House Bill 592
as an expedient to legislate thank you I
if I may say one more thing before
um uh there was a earlier testimony
mentioned about tree cutting I do want
to mention that in 2012 uh planning uh
changes to the 674 restricted planning
boards ability to regulate tree cutting
and they can only do that as part of
subdivision or site plan approval so
outright tree cutting is not
um
restricted except under
subdivision and site plan approvals so
that's where buffers can be in place and
vegetation
non-disturbance can be required okay
thank you
any questions by members of the
committee
seeing none thank you very much thank
in the New Hampshire Timberland Owners
Association
well good afternoon uh for the record
I'm Jason stock I'm with the New
Hampshire Timberland Owners Association
I didn't plan to actually speak on this
bill
but the question of tree cutting has
come up and buffers and and so forth and
as the prior speaker spoke the the the
state statute was changed RSA 674 1
Roman 6 which is very clear it states
that planning boards shall not have the
authority to regulate Timber harvesting
except in the case of projects subject
to to uh
site plan review it's or subdivision
excuse me those are the two subdivision
or site plan review
this was a piece of legislation that we
had worked on
um a lot of merchantable Timber does
grow in what are technically Wetlands
when you look at the three criteria and
you look at certain tree species red
Maples a great example of a tree species
that can infect and does grow in in
soils that are that would that could be
considered Wetlands so
um and right now to harvest Timber you
can harvest in a wetland legally you can
harvest in the Upland as well if you're
going to harvest in the Wetland though
the laws and rules are very clear you
have to do it under Frozen or dry
conditions
and if there is a channel if there's a
defined Channel you're obligated to get
a Wetlands permit to cross that channel
to access the other side so if you think
of a forest you think of a brook you got
a defined Channel you either Bridge it
or you put in a Ford of some type to
cross that there's a wetland permitting
process Des regulates that we also have
forest rangers across the state that
also have regulatory Authority so Timber
harvesting has and does occur in in
Wetlands it is not uncommon like I said
many tree species red maple Spruce fur
particularly up north you get up north
you'll see a lot of what what are
considered technically Wetlands it's
merchantable Timber it's been managed
for Generations
so I wanted to provide that that Clarity
the last thing I'll mention is that this
question about Wetlands Authority was
tested in court in Rockingham Superior
Court
um Justice Delker made a decision I
think it was the town of North
I get my Hamptons confused I think it
was Northampton there was a town with a
Wetlands ordinance had buffers they went
to do a Timber Just a standard Timber
sale their Forester
uh ran into the the town came in and
issued a cease and desist
the landowner
in this case Ron and Nancy bottom
um took the decided to challenge the
ordinance it went to the Rockingham
Superior Court and Justice Delker was I
couldn't be any couldn't be any clearer
he actually issued he said that the
ordinance did not have standing as
pursuant to this to 674 and in fact he
issued a writ of mandamus in this case
for the town to sign the intent to cut
so that they could begin harvesting so
which is a writ of mandamus is usually a
pretty intense order for a judge to
actually sit and tell a town order them
to do something
so this this law is on the books and it
has been tested
um Timber harvesting it's an ephemeral
activity it comes it goes the trees grow
back and we actually have landowners
that will manage land in for in Wetlands
for wildlife to create new growth for
yes we do have members that want to
attract beavers to their property and
they want to get saplings up because
that's what beavers like to eat so with
that I'll conclude my testimony and I'll
be happy to answer any questions
any uh any questions from the rep
representative Darby thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question so
you're cutting in these Wetlands you
have to cross these buffers to get to
the wetlands true so how do you work
with the local towns to get permission
to cross the buffers
great question the buffers are
considered Uplands and so those are
those the buffer areas and and this is
where I think some of the confusions
coming in the buffers deal with projects
that are typically associated with site
plan review
or subdivision forestry and as you heard
in some of the prior speakers on these
Wetlands overlay districts towns across
the state are crystal clear traditional
uses such as Ag and Forestry you're
you're not obligated to get an approval
or permission to do Forest Management in
these areas so the short answer to your
question is you're not obligated to
um and most landowners don't get
permission because they don't need to
it's part of their their forestry
project
thanks a lot
see none
thank you thank you very much
Arnold final Court card is Carol Foss uh
good afternoon chair and Zulu and
members of the committee my name is
Carol Foss I am Senior advisor for
Science and policy at New Hampshire
Audubon I do have written testimony that
I will hand out and I don't want to
reiterate
um testimony that you've already heard
but I will keep it brief and just say
that regardless of
which law this might might wind up
amending
um
small
impacts to Wetland buffers can have
large consequences Downstream and
temporary impacts to buffers can have
long-term consequences and I will leave
it at that and leave you with my written
testimony thank you
there any questions by members of the
committee
seeing none can allow you to ask you to
pass out your
I'll wait for it
can I ask you a question we have one
more
thank you I appreciate it
um I just want to clarify for the record
so you are opposed to correct I'm sorry
foreign
Mr chair is it possible for us to get a
summary of what the blue the sign-ins
were
okay
um well speaking for myself I do check
the portal on my own but
um I know that it has been practice of
the committee in the past to give a
two
if you bring them up or read them out of
Mr chair I just checked the online
testimony for this bill that we were
just working on and that one is 105 135
House Bill 186 is nine
uh
I'll just still give you the number
is on house house bill well this is for
me
House Bill 20205
there was uh two people there was four
people signing two people or Pro and two
didn't were neither Pro or con
and House Bill 214 no people signing
House Bill 310
uh two people con and one person no no
not for or against
uh
there were three people signing
one pro one con and one no no comment
and finally
there was one person Pro one two three
person Khan and one person
right in the middle no comment
that's it
thank you Mr chair I did say 135 but I
didn't say that there was a 135 that
opposed and five that support on that
bill okay and if there are other ones
that you want me to look at no I think
for the electronic
no I would I would uh I should have they
should have been done with the uh
uh with the elect then we well
we should I should have done them but uh
we've everybody wants to leave so thank
you oh I will declare the hearing
adjourned as being that no one seeing
Noah no other no other pink cards
hearing is adjourned
okay folks tomorrow we have
a session right sir are we all ready you
know you know we should know where your
uh you can leave them right here okay
well you're gonna take you're gonna pick
them up